Hallo und herzlich Willkommen zu Raumzeit, dem Podcast über Raumfahrt und andere.
Kosmische Angelegenheiten.
Und nach dem Ausflug in die Atomphysik, die letzten sechs Ausgaben am CERN,
kehren wir heute mal wieder zur Kernkompetenz dieses Podcasts zurück.
Und ja, es geht mal wieder über Raumfahrt und dazu habe ich mich nach Heidelberg
begeben ins Haus der Astronomie,
was passenderweise auch schön hoch auf dem Berg sitzt, hier auf dem Königsstuhl
zum Max-Planck-Institut für
Astronomie und begrüße erst mal meinen Gesprächspartner, nämlich den Knut.
Hallo, guten Morgen, guten Tag.
Hallo, ja herzlich willkommen bei Raumzeit. Max Planck Institut für Astronomie,
das macht hier was? Astronomie, okay gut.
Alles, alles, wir machen alles. Wir haben tatsächlich ganz viel Forschung,
Instrumentenbau im Bereich Astrophysik.
Es gibt Leute die machen Galaxien-Entstehungssimulationen, Sternentstehungssimulationen, Planetenformationen.
Also wir sind extrem breit aufgestellt was Astronomie und Astrophysik angeht.
Ursprünglich, damals in den 70ern, wurde es gegründet, das Institut,
als sozusagen Betriebs- und Grundlageninstitut für das Cala Alto Observatorium in Spanien.
Da sollte es ein deutsches Observatorium geben, das gibt es auch weiterhin.
Und dies war sozusagen das Institut, wo die Instrumente gebaut wurden,
die Planungen liefen, das ist sozusagen die Verbindung in den Norden.
Und seitdem hat sich das entwickelt. Wir machen immer noch ganz viel Instrumentenbau
für bodengebundene und Weltraummissionen in Observatorien,
Teleskope und haben aber parallel ganz viel Astrophysik, um mit den Daten,
die dazu reinkommen, Grundlagenforschung zu machen.
Gibt ja noch ein ganz basices Gebäude hier, was, wenn man von oben schaut,
aussieht wie so eine abstrakte Galaxie.
Genau, das ist das Haus der Astronomie hier direkt nebendran.
Das ist aus dem Kontext Outreach hier oder Öffentlichkeitsarbeit,
Lehrerfortbildung, Schülerinnenfortbildung hervorgegangen vor mehr als zehn Jahren.
Und macht alle möglichen Projekte im Bereich Astro-Ausbildung,
Fortbildung, viel oder hauptsächlich für Multiplikatoren.
Also LehrerInnen können hierher kommen und Fortbildung machen.
Wir haben auch TeacherInn-Residents,
die Sachen, sagen wir mal, entwickeln, Materialien entwickeln,
um in Süddeutschland, und ich glaube das geht mittlerweile über ganz Deutschland
hinweg, im deutschsprachigen Raum, Materialien zur Astro-Fortbildung anzubieten.
Grundlagen, Multiplikatoren sozusagen von dem, was wir alles erforschen,
dass das irgendwie auch in den Schulen verankert wird,
besser verankert wird und wenn man besseres Material zur Verfügung stellt,
mehr Material zur Verfügung stellt und Leute hilft, besser ausgebildet zu sein,
dann wird sich das in der Zukunft immer wieder bezahlt machen und das gibt's
seit über zehn Jahren, ist tatsächlich nach M51 der Spiral Galaxie ursprünglich
entwickelt worden als Grundlage für die Architekten und sehr spacig, ja.
Selbstbäßig, genau. Und es ist halt nicht nur ein Ort, wo diese Materialien
entwickelt werden, sondern wo auch Schulklassen und andere hinkommen können.
Genau. Es sitzt auch Stern- und Weltraum drin. Größtes deutsches Amateurastronomie Magazin.
Die haben ihre Redaktionsräume dort. Wir haben Studios für Produktion von Audio,
Video und ganz viele Sachen für Schulen, Ich glaube ab Kindergarten,
Experimentierräume, audiovisuelle Sachen, Dinge zum wirklich physischen Experimentieren
für die ganzen Schulen aus dem Umkreis.
Touchiert habe ich das Thema auch schon mal 2020, als ich mit Caroline Liefke gesprochen habe.
Die ist dort aktiv und da ging es auch dann um Amateurastronomie,
nicht so spezifisch jetzt um das Haus der Astronomie, aber das kam auf jeden
Fall dort auch noch zur Sprache Raumzeit 87.
Wer da vielleicht noch mal reinhören will. Aber heute soll es ja um richtige
Raumfahrt gehen und das Max-Planck-Institut ist hier beteiligt bei einer ESA-Mission,
nämlich der Mission Euclid und das steht sozusagen heute im Mittelpunkt.
Euclid ist ein neues Weltraumteleskop, was jetzt gerade vor wenigen Monaten
gelauncht wurde, erfolgreich.
Und ja, darüber würde ich mich natürlich mit dir ganz gerne unterhalten,
aber vielleicht erstmal noch zu dir.
Wie bist du denn in dieses Thema reingeraten?
Wie bin ich da reingeraten?
Sehr gute Frage. Also ich bin Astrophysiker, vom Studium her.
Ich hab in Hamburg seiner Zeit studiert.
Ich war dann in Potsdam und bin dann hier als Postdoc ins Institut gekommen,
hatte dann eine Forschungsgruppe, mehrere Jahre,
im Bereich Schwarze Löcher in
Galaxien, da arbeite ich immer noch in dem Bereich und dann gab sich 2011,
dass Euclid am Horizont sich als tatsächliche,
nicht nur als Studie und als Konzept abzeichnete, sondern dass die ESA das wahrscheinlich
oder möglicherweise als Mission akzeptieren, adoptieren und dann bauen wird
und das entschied sich 2011.
Und zu dem Zeitpunkt waren im Prinzip die Leute hier,
die unsere Beiträge zu dem Zeitpunkt oder bis dahin vorbereitet hatten,
waren auf dem Absprung und sagten,
okay, das war alles gut, wunderbar, wir suchen jetzt jemanden,
der unsere Instrumentierungsbeiträge, die wir liefern und haben könnten,
koordiniert, der auch unsere funktionale Sachen, die wir während der Mission
anbieten, koordiniert.
Und der dann auch die Rolle des sogenannten Instrumentwissenschaftlers für einen
der Instrumente übernehmen kann.
Dann hab ich gesagt, hey das klingt eigentlich sehr spannend,
das wird länger dauern und das war wie gesagt 2011,
jetzt bin ich ein Dutzend Jahre dabei, immer noch in der Funktion als Instrumentwissenschaftler,
können wir dann zukommen und wir haben in dem Zeitpunkt dann Instrumentierung
entwickelt und viel an Konzeptionen mitgearbeitet.
Das heißt, es ist wirklich der Zugang über die Forschung gekommen.
Ich habe großes Interesse an den Daten, die kommen werden, wenn ich auch kein
Kosmologe bin. Das ist eine Kosmologie-Mission, werden wir drüber sprechen.
Aber die Daten sind einfach sehr, sehr spannend. Die Bilder,
die Spektren, die da kommen werden, werden sehr, sehr spannend sein und berühren
ganz viele Sachen, mit denen ich vorher gearbeitet habe.
Ich habe im Hubble-Teleskop gearbeitet, bodengebundene Daten,
optisch, infrarot und dementsprechend, viele Sachen kamen mir sehr bekannt vor,
nur dass es halt jetzt um sehr, sehr viele Daten gibt über einen sehr großen
Himmelsbereich und Dinge, die man einfach von der Erde aus nicht machen kann
und das ist das, was damals spannend war, was jetzt auch noch spannend ist für
mich als jemand, der aus der Forschung kommt.
Ja aber wenn du dich schon immer mit Galaxien und schwarzen Löchern in Galaxien
beschäftigt hast, inwiefern ist das dann nicht Kosmologie?
Also wo siehst du da so den Unterschied?
Ich glaube Kosmologie offiziell ist sozusagen wirklich die Struktur des Universums
im Ganzen, wenn man mal diese ganzen kleinen Sachen, die Galaxien oder so mal
im Detail so weglässt, ne?
Also wir haben wir haben da einfach ganz große
Baustellen Ich sage immer mal scherzhaft
also vor 105 Jahren wussten wir eigentlich alles was im Universum so so da ist
da gab es so die große Diskussion was sind Galaxien die Great Debate sind das
Nebel von irgendwas in unserer Milchstraße oder sind das Dinge die wie unsere Milchstraße.
Nur außerhalb weiter weg sind. Und danach hat man gesagt, okay,
wunderbar, wir wissen jetzt, was Galaxien sind, wir alle die Nebel,
die können wir erklären.
Da haben wir gesagt, wir kennen eigentlich alles, was wir im Bereich so...
Wir nehmen ein Teleskop, gucken in den Himmel, sehen was. Das ist alles das.
Ja, man kann größere Teleskope nehmen, kann weitergucken. Das war alles das,
was wir von uns auch kennen.
Wir sehen die Sonne, wir sehen die Planeten, wir sehen die Sterne um uns herum.
Fertig. So. Dann kam halt irgendwann ein paar Jahrzehnte später,
stellte man fest, Galaxien rotieren nicht wie sie sollten, sie rotieren irgendwie
so, als ob da mehr Masse drin ist, als wir leuchtend sehen.
Galaxienhaufen bewegen sich nicht so wie sie sollten, da ist mehr Masse drin
als wir sehen und wenn man das mal genau ausrechnet, dann kommt man dahin,
dass da viermal mehr, fünfmal mehr Masse sein muss, als wir uns mit leuchtenden
Sternen oder Gas im Hintergrund erklären können.
Das waren dann die dunkle Materie, weil...
Materie leuchtet nicht. Dunkel. Ja, okay. Da haben wir dann schon mal irgendwie
gesagt, dass da fehlen uns irgendwie dann...
Vier Fünftel oder so von dem was wir kennen. Vier Fünftel wissen wir nicht,
ein Fünftel kennen wir ja so und dann haben wir natürlich weiter geguckt und
dann kam vor gut 20 Jahren die Sache mit den wir gucken uns an wie eine Standardkerze
in diesem Fall Supernovae so an Helligkeiten mit sich bringen wenn sie weiter
und weiter entfernt sind.
Also eine bestimmte Art von Sternexplosionen, von denen man relativ aus bestimmten
physikalischen Herleitungen heraussagen kann, wie hell sie sind und dadurch
hat man eine Referenz, sodass man das gemessene Licht direkt in Distanz umsetzen kann.
Genau, denn unser Grundproblem in der Astronomie ist, wir können ja anders als zum Beispiel am CERN,
wir können nicht einfach Sachen aufeinander schießen und dann die Ergebnisse angucken,
wir können auch nicht großartig warten, bis sich Galaxien irgendwie entwickelt
haben oder groß durch die Gegend bewegt haben, das heißt, wir müssen immer mit
Schnappschüssen arbeiten.
Wir können immer nur gucken und versuchen aus Sachen, die in verschiedenen Entfernungen
sind, weil wir wissen, Lichtgeschwindigkeit ist endlich, okay,
weitere Entfernung heißt, wir gucken in die Vergangenheit zurück.
Das ist gut, wir müssen uns das aber irgendwie zusammenbauen mit indirekten
Markern und wie du es so schön erklärt hast,
wenn ich nicht weiß, dass irgendetwas mit einer bestimmten Helligkeit leuchtet,
Dann kann ich auch nicht sagen, okay, ich weiß, die Leuchtkraft ist so und so
groß, die Helligkeit, die bei uns ankommt, ist so und so groß,
also kann ich eine Entfernung abschätzen.
Das heißt, wir brauchen als eine Sache so Standardkerzen, wie wir sie halt nennen.
Und die Supernovae sind genau das.
Wenn man ein bisschen rummodelliert, dann sagen wir, okay, wir können bestimmte
Sachen, bestimmte Eigenschaften von denen, Abklingengeschwindigkeiten und so weiter, nehmen.
Dann können wir daraus berechnen, welche Leuchtkraft sie tatsächlich haben.
Und dann können wir wirklich gucken, okay, wir gucken uns Supernovae an,
die in der Galaxie in 5 Milliarden Lichtjahren Entfernung, gucken was bei uns
an Helligkeit ankommt und sagen okay, das ist die Entfernung.
Als Leute das gemacht haben und dann gesagt haben, irgendwie nimmt das aber
mit der Entfernung nicht so ab, wie wir das eigentlich erwarten.
Das passt nicht dazu, dass wir ein einfaches Modell haben vom Urknall,
da sind wir wieder bei der Frage, was ist Kosmologie.
Urknall, das Universum expandiert seitdem und wir haben eigentlich angenommen, ja da ist Materie drin.
Materie, Masse hat nur eine Sache, Anziehungskraft. Das heißt,
es gibt keine, andererseits bei elektrischen Ladungen, positiv,
negativ, Masse ist da, Masse hat Anziehungskraft, das heißt,
wenn da irgendwas auseinanderfliegt und da ist Masse, dann bremst die eigentlich
dieses Auseinanderfliegen ab.
Ja und das was mit den Supernova dann gesehen wurde ist, dass das nicht damit
konsistent ist, das funktioniert nicht, sondern wir sehen, dass eigentlich die
Geschwindigkeit der Expansion zunimmt, beschleunigt.
Also dass es eine Expansion gab, das war schon vorher klar,
aber es war nicht klar, ob nicht vielleicht die ganze Materie irgendwann sozusagen
die Beschleunigung einer ursprünglichen Explosion oder so etwas ähnliches dann
irgendwann mal wieder einfängt Und das ganze Universum dann wieder in sich zusammenfällt.
Genau, entweder zusammenfällt oder gegen einfach eine niedrige Geschwindigkeit
konvergiert, die dann zwar immer noch weiter auseinander geht,
aber deutlich langsamer als vorher.
Dass es die Expansion gibt, dass es einen Urknall gab im Sinne von einem Zustand,
als alles sehr sehr sehr viel dichter beieinander und sehr sehr sehr viel heißer
war, das ist eigentlich seit Hubble in den 20er Jahren, 30er Jahren dann klar gewesen.
Also nicht Hubble das Weltraum-Testkorb, sondern der nach ihm benannt wurde.
Hubble die Person.
Aber dass es jetzt irgendeinen Faktor gibt, der nicht abbremst,
sondern sogar beschleunigt, das war neu.
So und das heißt, wenn man das wieder zurückgeht und dann noch was anderes dazu nimmt,
nämlich zu sagen, okay wir wissen seit solchen Missionen wie WMAP oder Vorgängern oder Planck,
Dass das Universum eine bestimmte Krümmung hat und dann wenn man da Modelle
dran füttert, dann heißt das, okay, wir können daraus berechnen,
welchen Energieinhalt es im Universum ungefähr gibt.
So, und wenn man den berechnet, dann kommt man darauf, da fehlen uns weiterhin
70 Prozent, auch wenn man dunkle Materie und normale Materie,
leuchtende Materie zusammenzählt.
Und wenn man dann die Supernovae dazu nimmt und sagt, da ist noch eine Beschleunigung dabei,
da ist ein Druck, dann kommt man auf irgendwas ganz Merkwürdiges,
dann kommt man nämlich auf ganz viel Energie, die da sein muss,
die wir bisher noch nicht gesehen haben, die aber nicht wirkt wie normale Masse,
nämlich anziehend, sondern die abstößt.
Das heißt, das ist irgendwie ein Druckfaktor. Irgendwie so eine Art Druck,
wie so ein Gas in einem Ballon.
Es hat einen Druck, hat auch Masse, aber irgendwas führt dazu,
dass da ein Druck nach außen ist und nicht einfach das Gas sagt,
ah, ich hab ja nur eigentlich Schwerkraft, ich fall ineinander zusammen,
ansonsten interessiert mich der Rest nicht. Ne, da ist ein Druckterm.
Und aus den Modellen, die im Prinzip an WMAP und Plank und so dran modelliert wurden, ist klar...
Wie groß der Energieinhalt ist und aus den Supernova Beobachtungen ist klar,
dass da eine Beschleunigung da ist. Und das ist etwas, was wir mit unseren ganzen
Elementarteilchen, unseren ganzen Feldern, die wir kennen, nicht beschreiben können.
Und ja, in der Abgrenzung zur dunklen Materie, die wir nicht verstehen,
hat man gesagt, ha, dann nennen wir das mal nicht dunkle Materie,
sondern dunkle Energie.
Haben wir also einen neuen Begriff, der uns erstmal die Angst nimmt vor dem Unbekannten,
aber in der Summe ist es halt so, anders als 1920 war dann 2020 klar,
dass wir irgendwie von 95% der Energie, die wir im Universum irgendwie feststellen
und messen und mit den Modellen vorhersagen und sehen können,
dass wir von denen nicht wissen, was es ist.
Und das ist natürlich ein, sagen wir mal, für Grundlagenforschung etwas unbefriedigender
Zustand, deswegen gibt es ganz, ganz viele Versuche, mehr Licht ins Dunkel zu bringen.
Sehr viele Theorien, die gemacht wurden, aus welchen Zusammenhängen könnte bestehen,
aus aktuellen Teilchen oder aus Erweiterung des sogenannten Teilchenstandardmodells,
wo gesagt wird, okay, wenn wir darüber hinausgehen, da gibt es mögliche Erweiterungen,
da könnten neue Teilchen sein, die eventuell dunkle Materie dann haben, also die Masse haben,
die wir aber so im Alltagsleben oder im Alltagsbeschleunigerleben auch nicht
sehen, die diese dunkle Materie darstellen könnten. Was sehr recht exotisches.
Da könnten wir, sind andere Teile von Theorien, beschreiben dann die dunkle Energie.
Gehen wir zurück zu Einstein. Einsteins Feldgleichung der allgemeinen Relativitätstheorie
hatten da so einen komischen Faktor drin,
so eine Integrationskonstante, von denen er auch nicht genau wusste,
was er damit anfangen sollte und sagte, gut, es gibt eigentlich aktuell zwar
formal diese Integrationskonstante, aber es gibt keinen Grund,
warum die nicht Null sein sollte, also ignorieren wir die mal.
Kosmologische Konstante, sagen wir, ist gleich Null.
Und hundert Jahre später stellte man fest, also im Prinzip wäre das,
was wir hier sehen an dunkler Energie, an dem Effekt der Abstoßung bei gleichzeitig
Energieinhalt, das ist im Prinzip kompatibel mit so einer kosmologischen Konstante.
Zumindest grob der Effekt wäre derselbe, wenn diese kosmologische Konstante
aus Einsteins Feldgleichung halt nicht Null wäre.
Hat dann spezielle Eigenschaften und es gibt alternative Varianten,
alternative Dinge, die nicht sich darauf beziehen.
Quintessenz, kann ich auch nicht viel zu sagen, zeitveränderliche Energieinhalte,
zeitveränderliche Abstoßungen, teilweise angebunden an die inflationäre Expansion des Universums.
Einen ganz frühen Universum, wo in den ersten Millisekunden das Universum plötzlich
um einen Skalenfaktor, weiß ich nicht, sehr viel größer wurde,
was im Prinzip etwas sehr Ähnliches ist, wie wir es jetzt sehen.
Eine Beschleunigung der Ausdehnung, aber auf sehr viel kürzeren Zeitskalen damals,
aber einfache Modelle sind immer elegant.
Wenn wir sowas im frühen Universum hatten und sowas in langsamer Heute sehen,
könnte es da eventuell Zusammenhänge geben, dass wir irgendwie nur eine langsame
Variante des Ganzen immer noch oder schon wieder haben.
Und darum dreht sich sehr viel in der Theorie, wo ich überhaupt keinen detaillierten
Einblick habe, weil es sehr komplex ist.
Aber im Prinzip das Gute ist, diese ganzen Zweige, sowohl im Bereich dunkler
Energie als auch im Bereich dunkler Materie, machen teilweise sehr unterschiedliche Vorhersagen.
Und wenn sie unterschiedliche Vorhersagen machen, können wir die testen.
Und das ist die Grundlage für viele kosmologische Himmelsdurchmusterungen,
viele kosmologische Projekte, die versuchen besser und besser diese Modelle
im Prinzip voneinander abzutrennen, indem sie diese Vorhersagen angucken und
sagen, okay, es passt zu dem Modell, aber es ist nicht kompatibel mit diesem Modell.
Ja und es gibt zahlreiche Missionen, die versuchen diesen ganzen Fragen auf den Grund zu kommen.
Wir hatten hier bei Romsat ja auch schon so einige, nicht zuletzt natürlich
das James-Webb-Teleskop,
was jetzt gestartet ist, was ja mit seiner Infrarot-Kamera auch tief ins Universum.
Hineinschaut und auf die Suche geht nach weiteren Anhaltspunkten und Erklärungen.
Für eben genau diese ganze Fragestellung.
Das heißt, wir haben eigentlich gar keine Messdaten, wirklich,
über sehr, sehr lange Distanzen. Und dann haben wir gesagt, okay, was wäre denn, wenn...
Unsere Gravitations-, unsere Schwerkraftmodelle einfach auf großen Skalen irgendwie
anders funktionieren würden.
Und da gibt es einen großen Theoriehinterbau auch und das sind Sachen,
die einfach in diesem Zusammenhang einfach mit abgetestet werden können.
Also es ist wirklich sehr stark von Standardphysik bis hin auch zu Alternativen.
Ich würde jetzt nicht sagen, was ist, wenn von außen nicht gegengedrückt wird
und so weiter, aber im Rahmen unseres Verständnisses geht es schon sehr,
sehr weit. Ja, ich hab das, ja.
Wollen wir das mal nicht vertiefen.
Genau, aber es gibt verschiedene Thesen im Raum, also Mond ist ja hier so das
Stichwort, modifizierte Newtonische Dynamik, das ist ein bisschen schwer auszusprechen.
Genau, also es wird alles mögliche ins Feld geführt und keiner weiß irgendwas
Genaues. Und deswegen müssen neue Missionen gestartet werden und genau das ist
ja jetzt hier gemacht worden.
Mit der Euclid Mission. Und da stellt sich natürlich vor allem auch erstmal die Frage so, warum das?
Warum reichen nicht die anderen Missionen, wie zum Beispiel James Webb,
was jetzt gerade gestartet wurde, wenn das auch mit so einem Infrarotteleskop
ausgestattet ist? Das muss doch dann irgendwie reichen.
Also ich hab ja schon gesagt, das ist eine ESA Mission, die NASA ist da allerdings
auch mit im Spiel und halt verschiedene wissenschaftliche Institute.
MPI hat ja wahrscheinlich einen relativ großen Anteil an der Mission.
Kann ich gleich erklären, ja.
Genau. Heißt Euclid oder Euclid geht wahrscheinlich auf Euclid von Alexandria
zurück, dem mysteriösen griechischen
Mathematiker, der aus irgendwelchen Gründen in Ägypten gewohnt hat.
Viel weiß man glaube ich nicht. Nee, wirklich viel weiß man nicht.
Aber Hintergrund ist Geometrie und bei ihm ging es um Geometrie und bei Euclid
der Mission, bei uns geht es eigentlich auch um Geometrie, nämlich des Universums an sich.
Und daher war der Name glaube ich sehr passend.
Genau, weil er sich im Prinzip die Sterne angeschaut hat und Aussagen und dann
eben auch entsprechende geometrische Betrachtungen über Aufgänge und so weiter
gemacht hat und das ist ja überhaupt erstaunlich,
dass eigentlich so derzeit das Bild der Griechen und der Ägypter schon relativ
klar war, dass die Erde irgendwie rund sein muss.
Dass das dann 2000-3000 Jahre später immer noch bezweifelt wird von manchen. Das ist bemerkenswert.
Genau, aber das war jetzt sozusagen der Namensgeber. Jetzt erklär uns doch mal,
warum braucht es diese Mission?
Und was sind die Ziele dieser Mission? Worauf will man jetzt eigentlich hinaus?
Also im Prinzip ist es so, die dunkle Energie dominierte noch nicht ganz im frühen Universum.
Die hat im Prinzip erst erheblichen Energiebeitrag geleistet in den letzten
zehn Milliarden Jahren, also nicht in den ersten zwei, drei,
vier Milliarden Jahren.
Das heißt, wenn wir uns Schnappschüsse angucken wollen,
dann hilft es uns nichts, wenn wir Schnappschüsse wirklich ein halbes,
halbe Milliarde Jahre nach dem Urknall oder früher oder so angucken,
das heißt, in erster Linie müssen wir nicht extrem früh zurückgehen.
So 10 Milliarden Jahre in die Vergangenheit, das sind Sachen mit denen Leute
seit 20 Jahren arbeiten, so wir können, mit Hubble können wir ganz klar dort
wunderschöne Galaxien angucken.
Und vor allem mit James Webb jetzt.
Und für James Webb auch, aber James Webb kann deutlich weiter,
wir haben schon Artikel veröffentlicht, die gehen halt bis 500 Millionen Jahre
nach dem Urknall, die ersten Quasare und die ersten Galaxienkandidaten jetzt
gesehen wurden, das ist noch deutlich früher.
Da müssen wir gar nicht hin. Was brauchen wir?
So ein mehr so moderneres Zeug.
Wir müssen etwas jüngere Dinge, weil nämlich erst seit ungefähr 10 Milliarden
Jahren die dunkle Energie anfängt zu dominieren in unserem Universum,
weil sich, und das ist halt eine Eigenschaft der dunklen Energie,
die hat im Prinzip sowas, vermutlich, ein Energieinhalt der pro Volumen konstant ist.
Und dann dehnt sich das Universum aus, das heißt wir haben einen Kubikmeter
Raum und da ist eine bestimmte Menge an dunkler Energie drin.
Und dann expandiert das Universum und Faktor 2 in jede Richtung ist größer und
plötzlich ist trotzdem in jedem Kubikmeter immer noch dieselbe Menge Energie drin.
Das heißt die Menge an Gesamtenergie in einem Volumen, was sich mit ausgedehnt hätte, hat zugenommen.
Was man ja eigentlich nicht erwarten würde.
Was man ja eigentlich nicht erwarten würde. Es wäre ein ganz klarer Verstoß
gegen lokale Energieerhaltung.
Aber wir reden halt hier von Dingen, die nicht einfach in Materie oder so umwandelbar sind.
Das heißt aber, dass im ganz frühen Universum die Dunkle Energie keinen großen Beitrag hatte.
Aber je größer das Universum wurde, desto größer wurde dieser Beitrag.
Und das heißt, wir müssen im Prinzip zwar nicht nur in unsere Umgebung gucken,
sondern bis 10 Milliarden Jahre in die Vergangenheit, aber nicht zwischen 10
und 11 und 12 und 13, 13 und ein halb.
Das heißt, wir brauchen gar nicht so extrem große, feine, tiefe Beobachtungen,
sondern nur Sachen, die ungefähr so gut sind wie das Hubble-Teleskop in ähnlicher
Art. So, das ist der eine Teil.
Der zweite Teil ist, die Methoden, mit denen Sachen angeguckt werden,
alle Marker, die wir nutzen und alle Marker, die auch vom Boden aus genutzt
werden, beinhalten sehr viel Anzahlstatistik über Galaxien.
Das heißt, es reicht nicht, wenn ich mir ein, zwei, drei Sachen sehr genau angucke.
Ich muss mir Anzahlen von Galaxien,
Dichten von Galaxien in bestimmten Entfernungen voneinander angucken.
Ich muss Stichworte schwache Gravitationslinseneffekt, Stichwort Baryon-Akustische Oszillation.
Das sind alles Sachen, die funktionieren nur, wenn man sehr,
sehr große Flächen, sehr, sehr große Volumina des gesamten Kosmos sich anschaut
und sehr, sehr viele Galaxien darin.
Das heißt, das, was JWST sehr, sehr gut macht, viele Seers da drin,
nämlich tief zu gucken, das kann Web über einen sehr kleinen Himmelsbereich.
Das heißt, wenn ich ein großes Feld am Himmel angucke, was JWST angeguckt hat,
dann meine Armausstrecke und meinen Fingernagel vom kleinen Finger angucke,
das deckt das völlig ab und viel, viel mehr.
So das heißt, wir können dort nur ganz kleine Volumen des gesamten Kosmos mit einem Bild abdecken.
So und das dauert dann trotzdem eine Stunde oder zwei. So und dann mach ich
das nochmal und nochmal und nochmal und so und irgendwann ist der Tag zu Ende
oder das Jahr oder die Missionszeit und ich hab trotzdem nur einen minimalen Bereich angeguckt.
Aber das ist ja auch Ziel, weil … Das ist das Ziel von JWST,
weil sie sehr sehr gut aufgelöst, sehr schwache Objekte … Man will ja genau
so eine alte Galaxie sich anschauen und sagen wie weit ist sie … Genau und in
Details und Galaxien selber zerlegen und so weiter.
Und das ist genau das Ziel dafür. Hilft uns aber nichts, wenn wir ein großes
Volumen des Kosmos tatsächlich angucken wollen.
Und Hubble ist ein bisschen besser, das Gesichtsfeld ist ein bisschen größer,
aber Hubble selber hat auch nur
in der gesamten Lebensdauer irgendwie 50 Quadratgrad am Himmel angeguckt.
Das kann man auch so mit zwei auseinandergehaltenen Fingern am Himmel so anzeigen.
Insgesamt, wenn man über alles summiert. Und wir brauchen ein Volumen,
Euclid wird 15.000 Quadratgrad, angucken, das ist mehr als ein Drittel des gesamten Himmels.
So, und das sind Sachen, die kann man vom Boden aus machen.
Aber nicht in der Qualität, die wir brauchen, was Auflösung angeht.
Und die kann man vom Boden machen, aber nicht im Wellenlängenbereich,
den wir teilweise brauchen, nämlich im Nahinfraroten, da ist zu viel Atmosphäre
vor. Und deswegen war ganz klar, für sehr feine Strukturen, die wir angucken
wollen, über einen ganz großen Himmelsbereich, brauchen wir was, was im Weltraum ist.
Und um sehr viele Galaxien anzugucken, relativ tief und sehr breit im Nahinfrarotbereich,
das geht auch nur aus dem Weltraum.
Und da war klar, wenn man diese beiden, diese ganzen Marker schafft, in einer,
oder diese Techniken in einer Mission zu verbinden,
denn es gab verschiedene Vorschläge für verschiedene Missionen,
die verschiedene kosmologische Sachen abtesten wollten,
dann hat man im Prinzip gewonnen, dann startet man ein Teleskop,
da reicht dann auch ein Spiegeldurchmesser von Euclid 1,20 Meter,
was halb so groß ist wie Hubble und ein Fünftel von dem, was JWST hat.
Das reicht an Lichtsammelfläche, weil wir nicht ins tiefste,
frühste Universum müssen.
Aber gleichzeitig kriegen wir ein riesengroßes Gesichtsfeld und können das,
was Hubble in seiner Lebenszeit an Fläche angeguckt hat, können wir in der Woche machen.
Also es ist eine klassische Survey-Mission, die einfach sagt,
okay, wir gucken jetzt mal vor allem einen möglichst großen Bereich,
weil wir wollen im Kern nicht einzelne Dinge beachten, sondern wir wollen eigentlich
eine Statistik aufbauen.
Ganz viel Statistik über Milliarden von Galaxien. So und jetzt muss ich ein
bisschen ausholen, was die Methoden angeht.
Also was wollen wir machen? Wir wollen zwei verschiedene Dinge im Prinzip,
also es gibt verschiedene Marker, die wir nutzen wollen, zwei Hauptdinge.
Eine ist der schwache Gravitationslinseneffekt, das heißt, Masse,
die sich irgendwo im Universum befindet, wenn da ein Lichtstrahl in der Nähe
vorbeigeht, Masse lenkt Licht ab.
Masse krümmt den Raum, Licht folgt dem Raum, also gibt's einen kleinen Bogen,
wenn irgendwo ein Lichtstrahl nahe einer Masse vorbeifliegt.
Wir kennen das vom starken Gravitationslinseneffekt, wo man vielleicht mehrere
Bilder kriegt von irgendeinem fernen Quasar, der geht nah an einer Galaxie vorbei
und plötzlich gibt es da eins, zwei, drei oder vier Bilder oder einen Ring,
Einstein-Ring, so genannten.
Das wäre dann, wenn etwas sehr dicht an einer sehr großen Masse vorbeigeht. Wir nutzen...
Das nicht. Wir wollen über größere Bereiche aus, sagen wir mal,
machen. Wir nutzen den sogenannten schwachen Gravitationslinseneffekt.
Das heißt, wenn also nicht mehrere Bilder erzeugt werden, was so eine Vordergrundmasse
trotzdem tut, ist die verbiegt im Prinzip die Form einer Galaxie,
die im Hintergrund ist. Wenn sie bei uns angekommen ist, sieht die nicht mehr
so aus oder ist das Bild nicht mehr so, wie sie tatsächlich aussieht.
Angenommene Galaxie würde ohne irgendwie eine Vordergrundmasse rund erscheinen.
Das Bild was bei uns ankommt, wenn das Licht von der Galaxie nah an so einer
Masse vorbeigeht, ist irgendwas Elliptisches in die Länge gezogenes.
Kleines bisschen, eventuell nur ein paar Prozent.
Sieht man ja jetzt auch schön auf den Bildern, die von JWST da erzeugt werden.
Wobei das ist der starke Gravitationslinseneffekt, da sieht man tatsächlich
gar nicht mehr die ursprüngliche Form.
Da wird irgendwas wirklich nur noch zum Streifen, aber auf der anderen Seite nochmal.
Bei uns wäre das im Prinzip so, ein Kollege hat das schön beschrieben,
wir müssen Formen analysieren und beschreiben können und den Unterschied zwischen
der Rundheit des Mondes und der Rundheit der Erde beschreiben können. Das sind irgendwie...
Also man misst mehr so die Wobbliness von allem sozusagen, ne?
Genau und da wir Annahmen machen können, wie Galaxien ursprünglich aussehen
und dass die im Prinzip nichts miteinander zu tun haben.
Wenn ich ein Hintergrundfeld von Galaxien angucke und die nicht zufällig alle
gerade miteinander zusammengestoßen sind, sondern Dinge in etwas unterschiedlichen
Entfernungen, dann haben die Formen und Orientierungen, wie jetzt so eine Galaxie
orientiert ist am Himmel, haben nichts miteinander zu tun. Das sollte eigentlich
zufällig verteilt sein.
Wie, was weiß ich, die Milchstraße von der leicht gekippt hat,
sieht irgendwie so leicht elliptisch aus.
Und wenn die irgendwo ist und irgendeine Galaxie in der Nähe ist,
dann sollten die eigentlich nicht alle parallel liegen mit ihren elliptischen Achsen. So.
Und was wir jetzt messen ist, wir messen diese Form und wir messen die Orientierung
und wenn wir da Effekte sehen, dass die doch korreliert sind über Himmelsbereiche,
dann wissen wir, da hat irgendjemand das Licht verzerrt.
Irgendetwas war da im Weg, das hat das Licht verzerrt, hat irgendwas ausgerichtet
und zwar in den Bildern, die wir sehen. Nicht natürlich, hat natürlich nichts
mit den Galaxien im Hintergrund zu tun, sondern nur wie das Licht gelaufen ist,
wie das Licht bei uns angekommen ist.
Und wenn da Korrelationen in diesen Ausrichtungen da sind, dann wissen wir,
das sind irgendwelche Massen.
Zwischen den Hintergrundgalaxien, die wir angucken und uns als Beobachter gelegen
haben, die diese, mit leichter Verzerrung des Raumes, diese Bilder ausgerichtet haben.
Dieser Gravitationslinseneffekt, das ist ja im Prinzip auch das,
was so Albert Einstein zum Superstar gemacht hat. Also er hat ja erst seine
Thesen postuliert und hier Relativitätstheorie und alle so, naaah, okay.
War halt so ein Paper, behauptet wird ja viel und aber seine These war ja,
dass man das im Prinzip genau an diesem Effekt gut abmessen konnte.
Dann gab es ja diese schöne Mission an den Pol, weil sich diese Gelegenheit
ergeben hat, dass ein Stern, von dem man eben wusste, wo er war,
im Prinzip hinter der Sonne hätte sein müssen.
Und zu einer Sonnenfinsternis gab es eben die Möglichkeit, das zu beobachten.
Den vorhergesagten Gravitationslinseneffekt.
Also eben, dass sich sozusagen das Licht um die Sonne herumbiegt,
weil eben auch die Sonne, weil eben auch das Licht eben von der Gravitation beeinflusst wird,
wie alles eben, und das war ja im Prinzip genau die Aussage der Relativitätstheorie,
alles, der Raum selbst krümmt sich und damit muss sich auch das Licht krümmen,
weil es eben gerade im Raum läuft, aber der Raum ist krumm.
Genau.
Und dann war halt dieser Stern zu sehen, obwohl man jetzt nach rein geometrischen
Maßstäben im Prinzip nicht hätte sehen können, da er eben eigentlich hinter der Sonne ist.
Und das war dann sozusagen der Moment, wo das losging. Und jetzt geht's bei
euch im Prinzip darum, diesen Effekt in schwacher Form überall möglichst weiträumig zu erfüllen. Genau.
Gravitationslinseneffekt oder Licht reagiert auf Masse, wie du richtig sagtest,
auf Masse. Und das ist egal, ob es leuchtet wie die Sonne oder leuchtet wie
eine Galaxie oder dunkle Materie ist.
So, und wenn wir wissen, okay, dunkle Materie ist mehr...
Oder ein schwarzes Loch.
Oder ein schwarzes Loch. So, wenn wir...
Ist auch dunkel. Gibt auch Möglichkeiten, dass schwarze Löcher ein Teil der dunklen Materie...
Aber schwarze Löcher sind deshalb dunkel, weil sie wirklich dunkel sind und
nicht, weil man nur das Wort benutzt, weil man nicht weiß, was es ist.
Ja, wir wissen aber schon, dass dunkle Materie im Prinzip keine oder so gut
wie keine elektromagnetische Wechselwirkung hat und Dunkelheit heißt ja irgendwie nur,
kein Licht heißt keine elektromagnetische Wechselwirkung und ob jetzt irgendwie
kein Photon da rauskommen kann oder ob es grundsätzlich ist,
dass die Materie keine Photonen imitiert, weil es an dieser Wechselwirkung nicht
teilnimmt, sondern nur Gravitation hat, ist erstmal egal.
Der Effekt ist derselbe, Masse ist Masse. Und das ist der Vorteil,
wenn wir nämlich jetzt so eine Kartierung machen über den Himmel,
auch wieder mit verschiedenen Galaxien,
Hintergrundgalaxien in verschiedenen Entfernungen, um verschiedene Weltalter
oder kosmische Zeitalter abzufragen, dann kriegen wir letztendlich eine Karte
von dem, was wir nicht sehen können, nämlich von der tatsächlichen Massenverteilung.
Und zwar über ein Drittel des Himmels, weil wir ein Drittel des Himmels kartieren,
und in der Tiefe in verschiedenen Epochen,
Und ich glaube, elf oder zwölf oder dreizehn Epochen fragen wir ab von vor zehn
Milliarden Jahren und neun und acht und sieben und so weiter zu den Zeiten bis
nahe an uns oder näher an uns ran und das heißt, wir bekommen tatsächlich eine
dreidimensionale Karte von Masse.
Und da wir es bei verschiedenen Epochen machen, können wir diese Karten oder
diese Statistiken über diese verschiedenen Epochen auch miteinander vergleichen.
Wie ist zum Beispiel das, was wir Clustering nennen.
Wie stark hat sich Materie zusammengeballt?
Weil irgendwo ganz früh im Universum, da war Materie fast gleich verteilt. So ganz früh.
Kosmische Hintergrundstrahlung. Ganz kleine Fluktuationen. So heutzutage,
wir sitzen an einem Tisch, der Tisch hat ganz klar eine viel höhere Dichte als
die Luft drumherum, die Erde hat eine viel höhere Dichte als die leeren Teile im Sonnensystem.
Wir haben ganz große Dichte-Kontraste.
Das heißt, es hat sich ganz viel entwickelt und auch die dunkle Materie hat
im Laufe der Zeit sich zu immer stärker und stärker zusammengeballten Strukturen zusammengefunden.
Das fing an mit leichten Dichte-Kontrasten und wo halt bisschen mehr Dichte war,
bisschen mehr Materie war, dort wurde halt etwas mehr Anziehungskraft ausgeübt,
als in den Bereichen, wo weniger Materie war und deswegen kam mehr und mehr
Materie zu den Bereichen,
wo schon mehr Dichte war oder mehr Materie war und das heißt,
es findet eine Entwicklung statt, es fand eine Entwicklung statt,
vom frühen Universum bis heute,
geht auch weiter und wenn wir uns verschiedene Zeitalter angucken,
können wir diese Statistiken über diese Materiekarten miteinander vergleichen,
wie sozusagen die Strukturentwicklung war im Universum.
Und das ist wieder so eine Sache, wir müssen halt gucken,
wie können wir verschiedene Schnappschüsse miteinander vergleichen,
wie können wir verschiedene Instanzen, die wir nur einmal beobachten sozusagen
und wo wir nicht warten müssen über eine Milliarde Jahre, das ist ein bisschen
lang für ein Projekt, miteinander vergleichen, um zu sagen, wir kommen zu einer
Entwicklung. Wir können uns eine Entwicklung anschauen.
Und das ist einer der fundamentalen Sachen. Wir können Strukturentstehung über
schwachen Gravitationslinseneffekt angucken.
Und das andere Haupt, der zweite Hauptmarker, neben anderem ist,
dass wir versuchen, der Expansionsgeschichte des Universums nachzuforschen.
Wieder die große Frage, woher zum Teufel wollen wir wissen, wie groß das Universum
vor zehn Milliarden Jahren war?
So, wir können zwar sehen, die Abstände zwischen zwei Galaxien sind so und so
groß, Aber wir wissen nicht, wie groß die Abstände zwischen diesen beiden Galaxien
eine Milliarde Jahre später oder fünf oder zehn Milliarden Jahre später ist,
weil wir halt die nur einmal sehen.
Die sehen wir nur zu dem Zeitpunkt vor zehn Milliarden Jahren,
weil wir uns Galaxien angucken, die zehn Milliarden Lichtjahre entfernt sind
und die Lichtlaufzeit so lang war und so weiter.
So, wenn wir uns vor fünf Milliarden Jahren einen Schnappschuss angucken,
sehen wir andere Galaxien.
So das heißt, wie verfolgt man die Expansionsgeschichte des Universums?
Und da gibt es genau eine Sache, die bisher gefunden wurde und das ist total
clever und es ist jedes Mal mindblowing, es gibt tatsächlich einen Längenmaßstab
im Universum, der sich mit dem Universum zusammen ausgedehnt hat.
Und der hat was zu tun mit dem, was man leicht von der Zunge gehend baryon-akustische Oszillationen nennt.
Baryonische akustische Oszillationen?
Ja, und das hat damit zu tun, dass wir im ganz frühen Universum,
also von dem Zeitpunkt, wo wir auch die kosmische Hintergrundstrahlung sehen,
Planck, diese schöne Karte, die man immer kennt, wo ganz leichte Fluktuationen
drin waren, zu dem Zeitpunkt.
Du redest von der kosmischen Hintergrundstrahlung, die ja irgendwann mal zufällig
entdeckt wurde und die dann eben von Planck konkret gemessen wurde,
wo man halt einfach dieses typische blau-rötliche Rauschmuster im Prinzip hat,
so was dann so ellipsoid abgebildet wird, was im Prinzip so einmal der Blick
in die Weite überall ist, was sozusagen die ganze Zeit noch so nachleuchtet
und das ist so das älteste Wärmesignal quasi der Universums.
Genau, das ist genau das Wichtige, das ist nämlich das älteste,
das ist der weiteste Blick, den wir zurück haben, weil das war ungefähr 379.000,
Jahre, also nicht Millionen oder Milliarden, sondern 379.000 Jahre nach dem
Urknall. Kann man aktuell relativ gut berechnen.
Vorher war das Universum so heiß, dass es keine Atome gab, es gab nur Protonen,
Atomwasserstoffkerne und Elektronen, die waren aber getrennt.
Bei zu hohen Temperaturen bekommen wir das, was wir auch jetzt Plasma nennen,
in irgendwelchen sehr heißen Flammen oder so kriegen wir Plasma,
wir kriegen eine Trennung dieser Ladung.
Wenn wir aber Ladungstrennung haben, dann kommen Lichtteilchen,
Photonen, kommen nicht weit. weit. Die werden sofort wieder absorbiert,
die werden irgendwie imitiert und sofort absorbiert. Das heißt,
die können sich nicht sehr weit bewegen.
Das heißt, das Universum war nicht transparent.
Das Universum war nicht transparent. Das heißt, erst nachdem das Universum so
abgekühlt war, dass aus Protonen und Elektronen ein Atom, ein Wasserstoffatom
wurde, gab's plötzlich kaum mehr Ladung, freie, und die Photonen konnten abhauen. und so.
Was aber früher schon passierte, das geht jetzt zurück zu dem, was ich eben erklärte.
Wir hatten schon leichte Kontraste in Massen oder Massedichten zwischen verschiedenen
Bereichen, links und rechts.
Das, was wir auch in der kosmischen Hintergrundstrahlung sehen bei diesen Karten
des ganzen Himmels. Ganz leichte Kontraste.
Da, das sind Massenunterschiede, die gab's auch, als das Universum noch Plasma
war. Und dort war wie danach auch Gravitationsanziehung.
Das heißt, Materie ist ganz leicht zu diesen höheren Dichten stärker hingegangen,
als in die Bereiche, wo niedrigere Dichten waren.
Jetzt gab's aber komische Effekte, dass, weil die Photonen so mit der Materie
immer mitlaufen mussten, weil sie nämlich nicht weit weg kamen,
kam das dazu, dass es dort zu einem Druck kam, wenn Sachen zusammenfielen oder
sich stärker zusammenballen wollten.
Und wenn wir Druck haben, dann gibt's wieder eine Abstoßung und dann sind wir
wieder abgestoßen und dann kommt wieder Gravitation und zieht das wieder an.
Das heißt, es kam da zu so einer Art Schwingung in dem frühen Universum vor
der Zeit von 379.000 Jahren.
Und da gibt's eine charakteristische Schwingung, eine Schwingungsamplitude,
eine Schwingungsgeschwindigkeit, die im Prinzip sagt, okay, mit dieser Geschwindigkeit
können, oder schwingt charakteristisch, schwangen charakteristisch,
Vergangenheit, zu dem Zeitpunkt diese Massen dichten.
Und dann wurde das Universum plötzlich transparent, 379.000 Jahre nach Murknall,
und dieser Druck verschwand, weil sich nämlich die Photonen plötzlich frei bewegen konnten.
Und was dazu führte, Schwingung heißt immer, oder charakteristische Schwingung
heißt immer eine charakteristische Wellenlänge.
Charakteristische Wellenlänge, weil irgendeine bestimmte Geschwindigkeit,
so. Und diese Wellenlänge war plötzlich eingefroren.
Die änderte sich nicht mehr. nämlich die charakteristische Wellenlänge genau
der Bedingungen direkt kurz vor 379.000 Jahren nach Murknall.
Da hat sich danach nichts mehr verändert, dieser Druck verschwand,
es gab keine neuen Schwingungen mehr, weil plötzlich gab es nur noch Schwerkraft,
keine Druckeffekte mehr von irgendwelchen gefangenen Photonen.
Und plötzlich war diese Wellenlänge eingefroren.
Leichten überdichten auf dieser entfernung zwar
in jede richtung welche wellenlänge war das und das
ist genau eine wellenlänge die einem die
ein maßstab ist die später immer
mehr und immer mehr sich immer mehr masse eingefunden
hat ich kann nicht sagen was das für eine entfernung ist mehr viele viele mega
parsec im heutigen universum aber auf dieser auf dieser auf dieser entfernung
auf diesem maßstab haben sich im laufe der zeit Zeit etwas mehr Galaxien charakteristisch
entwickelt, als auf allen anderen Marsstäben.
Das heißt, wenn ich mir einen Galaxienhaufen angucke, dann bekomme ich in dieser
Entfernung dieses Marsstabs etwas mehr Galaxien zu sehen,
wenn ich eine Statistik mache, als auf kleineren Abständen oder als auf größeren Abständen.
Und damit kann ich im frühen Universum, also nicht mehr ganz so frühen Universum
bei zehn Milliarden Jahren in der Vergangenheit, kann ich versuchen Statistik zu machen.
Ich gucke mir die Abstände von Galaxien an, vielen Galaxien,
und mache eine Statistik, wenn ich mir die Abstände von jeder Galaxie zu jeder
anderen Galaxie angucke und mir angucke, wie viele Galaxien sind am Abstand
von 1 Meter und 100 Lichtjahren und 10.000,
und 1 Milliarde Lichtjahre, wenn ich mir das angucke und dann eine Statistik
mache, dann bekomme ich irgendwann einen kleinen Peak, eine kleine Überdichte.
Das ist dieser Maßstab. Und wenn sich das Universum ausdehnt,
dann dehnt sich dieser Maßstab mit aus, weil...
Universum dehnt sich aus. So, das heißt, ich mach das nicht nur vor 10 Milliarden Jahren,
ich mach das auch vor 9 und vor 8 und vor 7 oder 6 und vor 5 und habe dann einen
Maßstab, den ich verfolgen kann und der ist, dieses Wachstum,
dieses Maßstabes gibt mir tatsächlich den Skalenfaktor an, wie das Universum
sich in dieser Zeit ausgedehnt hat.
Das heißt, ich kann tatsächlich ein sehr indirektes Lineal an das Universum
anlegen, vor 10 Milliarden Jahren, vor 9, 8, 7, 6 und kann messen,
wie groß, nein, nicht wie groß das Universum war, sondern wie sich das ausgedehnt
hat, wie sich das verändert hat.
Und wenn ich die Veränderung kenne, dann kenne ich die Ausdehnungsgeschwindigkeit
und wenn ich die Veränderung der Veränderung kenne, dann kenne ich die Beschleunigung.
Dann weiß ich, wird es abgebremst oder wird es beschleunigt.
Und damit hat man eine Zahl an die dunkle Energie,
damit habe ich eine Zahl, die ist charakteristisch und wenn ich die sehr sehr
sehr sehr genau messe, dann kann ich verschiedene Vorhersagen von verschiedenen
Theorien voneinander unterscheiden und das ist das Ziel.
Also das mit dem Lineal, das würde ich gerne nochmal ein bisschen besser verstehen,
also mit dieser Hintergrundstrahlung und überhaupt so diesem Blick in die Vergangenheit,
das ist ja irgendwie etwas, das muss man erstmal so ein bisschen in sich aufnehmen.
Was ja im Prinzip Plank gemacht hat ist, es schaut sich quasi,
also halt war ja auch ein Survey, also so ein Upscann des gesamten Universums,
in dem Fall halt auch wirklich so in jede Richtung, also die vollständige Kugel
und im Prinzip schaut sich ja dann das Teleskop, sagen wir mal,
den Teil an, der eigentlich schwarz ist.
Also man schaut sich natürlich alles an, aber da, wo eigentlich nichts ist,
ist halt trotzdem noch was.
Man sieht halt von den normalen Sternen, sieht man halt irgendwie das Licht,
was relativ stark kommt, aber überall ist ja irgendwas.
Auch wenn vieles schwarz wirkt, ist ja eigentlich nicht nichts und sozusagen die Wärme,
die dort noch, das Licht, was dort noch sichtbar ist, aber eben so stark ins
Infrarot verschoben ist, dass es also so super alt ist, das hat diese Karte ausgeführt.
Genau, Planck hat im Prinzip Infrarot-Licht gemessen, was das Überbleibsel ist
von dem, was damals sehr heiß war, aber die Strukturen, die dieses Licht ausgesandt
haben, waren irgendwelche Massen.
Genau, keine Sterne.
Keine Sterne, aber irgendwelche, haben aus irgendwelchen Massen und im Prinzip die Annahme,
die auch sehr gut gerechtfertigt ist, wenn wir etwas mehr Licht sehen,
dann kam dort, oder in diesem Fall eine etwas andere Temperatur sehen,
dann waren das etwas größere Massen, als wenn wir irgendwo anders eine etwas
niedriger Temperatur im Licht sehen.
Und dann kommt diese leichte Variation. Und in diesem Plasma,
in diesem Nicht-Zustand sozusagen, also in dem alles noch nicht in der Form war,
wie wir es heute kennen, dort hat sich dann eben diese Oszillation,
wie heißt es nochmal so schön, barionische, akustische Oszillation,
also akustisch nicht, weiß nicht.
Es waren im Prinzip Schallwellen, die aber niemand gehört hat,
weil es ging um die Geschwindigkeit, mit der sich im Prinzip Materie dort bewegen
konnte und das ist im Prinzip eine Art Dichte.
Genau, also ein Gewaber aus Strahlung und aus Gravitation sozusagen und das
ist ja dann in dieser Hintergrundstrahlung quasi rein codiert.
Das heißt das ist das was man, also man nimmt dieses BAO, diese baryonische
Akustik, dieses Lineal, entnimmt man der Hintergrundstrahlung.
Die entnehmen wir der Hintergrundstrahlung und damit kriegen wir einen Marker
bei 379.000 Jahren nach dem Urknall.
Das war aber der Zeitpunkt, wo dunkle Energie noch nicht besonders wichtig war,
weil sich das Universum noch nicht sehr stark ausgetehnt hatte und deswegen
die Frage, wie kriegen wir das viel viel viel viel später, nämlich vor 10 Milliarden und 987.
Und dort kriegen wir nicht nochmal eine neue Hintergrundstrahlung.
Die ist da seit der Zeit und bewegt sich seitdem durch die Gegend.
Das heißt, was nehmen wir? So und da ist ganz klar,
wenn wir Überdichten hatten, die seinerzeit am Anfang diese Temperaturfluktuation
in der Hintergrundstrahlung gemacht hatten, Überdichte bedeutet immer,
eine Überdichte wird zu mehr Überdichte, wird zu mehr Überdichte,
weil dort einfach mehr Materie drauf fällt.
Das sind die Orte, wo dann Galaxien entstanden sind.
Und wenn ich eine größere Überdichte habe, sind dort mehr Galaxien entstanden.
Wenn ich eine Unterdichte habe, sind dort weniger Galaxien entstanden im Laufe
der Zeit. Das heißt, wiederum diese überdichten Abstände im frühen Universum,
Zeigen sich dann später in Überdichten von entstandenen Galaxien und das ist
das Gute, weil Galaxien können wir sehen und Galaxien können wir einen 3D-Punkt
irgendwo hinsetzen und dann können wir Statistik machen.
Heißt das, dass sozusagen die Strukturen, die wir heute sehen,
die Verteilung der Materie im Prinzip eine
unmittelbare Folge aus diesem strahlungsdruckdichten Zusammenspiel ist?
Ja, in Teilen schon. Also in Teilen gab es ganz am Anfang Fluktuationen.
Wie groß die genau waren, wird debattiert.
Welche Formen die genau hatten, wird auch debattiert. Ist aber klar,
es gab eine leichte Verteilung von Dichten, von Energie im frühen Universum
oder Masse im frühen Universum und die war da.
So, und die ist nur stärker geworden im Laufe der Zeit. Die war irgendwie 10
hoch Minus, weiß ich nicht wie viel, ganz im frühen Universum,
jetzt haben wir große Dichte-Kontraste.
Diese baryon-akustischen Oszillationen
haben sozusagen nur noch einen draufgesetzt und haben gesagt,
okay, es gibt hier jenseits von dem, was vorher da war, gibt es aus der Kombination
von Gravitation, von diesem Druck, der passiert, und der möglichen Schallgeschwindigkeit
zu jedem Zeitpunkt, der von der Temperatur abhängt und so weiter,
gibt es eine charakteristische Länge.
Sozusagen auf die Karte oder auf diese Verteilung noch mal oben drauf geprägt.
Und alles was wir vorher hatten an Fluktuationen plus dieser drauf geprägte
Längenmaßstab, das ist das, was wir jetzt immer noch sehen können in der Galaxienverteilung.
Wir im Sinne von, ich gucke in den Himmel, nicht einfach, aber wenn ich ganz
genau messe, in drei Dimensionen, wo befinden sich Galaxien und da eine Statistik
drüber laufen lasse, dann kann ich diesen Maßstab nachvollziehen und zwar auch
zu verschiedenen Zeitaltern.
Ich hab grad so das Bild von so einer Metallplatte, wo Sand drauf ist,
wo man Geigenbogen irgendwie eine Frequenz anlegt und wo sich dann ja auch so
Muster, Schlatni Figuren oder sowas heißt das glaube ich, bilden.
Im Prinzip, dass auch durch dieses Zusammenspiel von Strahlung und Gravitation
eben in diesem Urzustand des Universums im Prinzip schon mal solche Frequenzen
dort eine Rolle gespielt haben und eine frühe Struktur geschafft haben,
die sich dann einfach in der Folge der nächsten 13 Milliarden Jahre einfach
verstärkt hat und dann quasi in diesen Filamenten resultiert, die wir heute sehen.
Also Galaxien ja, gut, das sehen wir jetzt nicht so mit bloßem Auge,
aber im Prinzip sind das ja alles schon solche langen Röhren von Galaxienhaufen,
die so mehr oder weniger miteinander in Anführungsstrichen verbunden sind und
dazwischen gibt es dann diese riesigen Voids, wo einfach mal gar nichts ist.
Und hätten wir nur die Anfangsbedingungen des Universums gehabt oder diese zufälligen
Sachen ganz vom Anfang, dann hätten wir erstmal keinen charakteristischen Längenmaßstab gehabt.
Ich glaube, das wäre relativ fraktal, chaotisch, wie auch immer gewesen,
aber durch diese Tatsache, dass es halt hier so zwei,
dass es hier eine Schwingung gab von Gravitation, Zusammenfall,
Druck, der das wieder auseinander gedrückt hat und der Tatsache,
dass das irgendwann abrupt aufgehört hat, der hat halt diesen Längenmaßstab
aufgeprägt, was halt ganz wichtig ist, denn die Schallgeschwindigkeit ist von
der Dichte und von den Temperaturen abhängig
Und die hat sich natürlich im frühen Universum durch das Ausdehnen ständig geändert.
Aber im Prinzip wurde der letzte Zustand direkt bevor das Universum transparent
wurde, hat sich, wurde aufgehoben, wurde bewahrt.
Und da im gesamten Universum die Temperatur so war und die Dichten ungefähr
so waren, war das auch im ganzen Universum gleich.
Und deswegen gilt dieser Längenmaßstab universell und auch ob ich nach rechts
oben gucke oder links unten gucke,
sollte ich den überall finden und da das Universum im Prinzip zum selben Zeitpunkt
überall schlagartig oder relativ schnell durchsichtig wurde,
müsste das auch miteinander korrelieren.
Und deswegen kann ich eine Statistik machen, die Teile links oben und Teile
rechts unten am Himmel miteinander korreliert und die Sachen einfach zusammenzählen.
Also zusammengefasst kann man erstmal sagen, so die Hauptziele der Mission sind
dunkler Energie und dunkler Materie auf die Spur zu kommen und darüber sozusagen Daten zu generieren,
mit dem man dann Rückschlüsse auf das Wesen dieser Phänomene schließen kann,
vielleicht, ja, Modelle einschließen kann, ausschließen kann,
weitere Anhaltspunkte zu liefern.
Sicherlich ist jetzt nicht das Ziel die finale Antwort zu liefern,
sondern sozusagen überhaupt erstmal eine Datenbasis zu schaffen.
Wir füttern die Theorie.
Wir füttern die empirische Basis, um
Theorien entweder auszuschließen oder weiterentwickeln zu können. Genau.
Und dann gibt es einerseits den Punkt dunkler Energie, da haben wir schon gehört,
da gucken wir einfach, okay, auf Basis der Urschwingung des Universums kurz
nach dem Urknall, also so als sozusagen das Licht angeknipst wurde.
Dann kriegen wir einen Maßstab und den Maßstab verfolgen wir über die Zeit und
können deswegen die Expansionsgeschichte des Universums nachvollziehen und wenn
die beschleunigt ist, dann können wir genau messen, was ist das für eine Art
Beschleunigung, wie ist die zeitabhängig oder ist die nicht zeitabhängig.
Das kann man direkt mit Theorie vergleichen.
Gibt's ja auch schon andere Annahmen und andere Messungen und die würden die
dann sozusagen nochmal ergänzen oder?
Genau, wir werden ganz viele dieser Ansätze miteinander verbinden und insgesamt
gibt das ein sehr, sehr feines Bild, was uns, was weiß ich, auf ein Prozent
genau die Expansionsgeschichte geben soll und das war halt vorher nicht möglich.
Genau. Und der zweite Schwerpunkt ist dunkle Materie,
also hier geht's dann eben konkret auf dieses was ist das eigentlich und wie
ist es verteilt im Universum und hier nimmt man diesen Effekt der schwachen
Gravitationslinsen, also man schaut sich im Prinzip irgendwie alles an,
Macht Annahmen darüber, wie es eigentlich aussehen sollte.
Wie ist der Hintergrund und was kommt an?
Und wie sieht es eigentlich wirklich aus, um dann in Rückschlüsse daraus zu
ziehen, die halt sozusagen eine Verteilung von diesem ominösen,
was auch immer es ist, Erlauf haben.
Und dann letztendlich testen wir damit, welche Eigenschaft hat eigentlich unser
Gravitationsmodell, was ist eigentlich Gravitation.
Weil es ist ein Test von Dingen, die Schwerkraft machen. Und damit haben wir wieder die Verbindung.
Das eine ist der Druckteil mit der dunklen Energie, das andere ist der Schwerkraftteil.
Wie wirken die Sachen zusammen und wie kann man das in eine kohärente,
möglichst einheitliche Theorie zusammenbringen?
Genau und nebenbei testet man wahrscheinlich auch nochmal Einstein ordentlich
durch, weil das ist ja dann immer sozusagen die Frage, gerade wo wir jetzt schon,
diese Mondtheorie und so weiter wäre ja im Prinzip auch eine Abweichung.
Ja Mond wäre eine Abweichung, das ist dann eine Variation von allgemeiner Relativitätstheorie,
die im Prinzip darüber hinausgehen würde.
Einstein hat doch bisher immer gehalten.
Ja, wir haben aber Einstein auch immer nur auf sehr, also wir werden es mittesten,
es ist eine formal korrekte Theorie,
die Sachen beschreiben kann und wenn wir eine Theorie haben,
die nicht aus unendlich vielen freien Parametern besteht, wo ich immer nur sagen kann,
aha ihr habt mich widerlegt, ich dreh mal hier, dann passt es trotzdem,
sondern wirklich falsifizierbare Sachen macht, dann sollte man das ernst nehmen
und sagen hey wir testen das mit und das machen wir und entweder wir können
es widerlegen oder wir können es nicht widerlegen.
Und das gilt aber für die ganzen anderen Sachen auch.
Ja und was machen wir? Wir gucken uns Galaxien an. Viele. Sehr viele.
Ja und so nebenbei, denke ich mal, dürfte man auch die ein oder andere Nebenerkenntnisse
auch noch über die Anfangsbedingungen des Universums als solchen herausfinden.
Und ich kann da später auch noch was zu sagen, ganz ganz viele Leute,
ganz viele WissenschaftlerInnen bei dieser Mission sind gar nicht an der Kosmologie interessiert.
Sondern wollen einfach nur diesen absolut wahnsinnigen Datensatz haben,
der dabei rauskommt, um damit alles mögliche zu machen.
Nämlich Galaxienentwicklung studieren oder Quasare im frühesten Universum finden
oder Sonnensystemobjekte finden und verfolgen und so weiter.
Also es wird auch ein Datensatz sein, der über die nächsten 20,
30 Jahre mindestens einfach der Standard ist für Bilder in diesen Wellenlängenbereichen.
So ein bisschen wie Gaia mit seiner Sternen-Kategorie, hier überhaupt erstmal
die Grundlage für die Forschung für die nächsten Jahrzehnte gelegt hat,
hier in ähnlicher Form, aber eher sozusagen large scale auf Galaxie-Basis.
Kommen wir doch mal so ein bisschen zur Mission selber und zu dem Raumfahrzeug.
So wann ging's los? Vor zwölf Jahren hast du gesagt?
Es ging sogar noch früher los, es gab vorherige Missionskonzepte,
Dune und Space, die im Prinzip zum einen schwachen Gravitationslinseneffekt
machen wollen und die andere Mission wollte diese barionakustischen Oszillationen
messen und dann wurden die zusammengefasst,
das hat 2005 angefangen, verschiedenste Leute hier im Haus und über ganz Europa
verteilt, hatten verschiedene Ideen was man denn eigentlich mal machen sollte
und die ESA hat immer mal wieder,
Also Aufrufe für Programmung, gesagt hey schlag Missionen vor,
erst mal auf Papier und dann irgendwann sagen wir mal okay, das klingt ganz
interessant, wir machen da mal eine Studie, was würde das bedeuten an optischem
Design, ist das überhaupt machbar mit aktueller Technik, was würde das kosten,
würde das in den Kostenrahmen passen und so weiter, macht Vorschläge.
Und da entstanden diese Konzepte, Dune und Space.
Und da wurde gesagt, hey, die einen wollen Infrarot und Bilder,
die anderen wollen auch Infrarot.
Können wir das nicht alles in einer Mission, aus zwei Konzepten eine Mission
machen? Und da wurde gesagt, hey, gut, müsste eigentlich gehen.
Ist billiger, weil eine könnte sowieso nur fliegen. Beides Kosmologie.
Kam der Vorschlag vom MPI oder wo ist der Dupont worden?
Wir spielen eine Rolle, ich glaube wir spielen, also komm ich gleich zu,
aber wir reden hier von 140 Institutionen über Europa,
wir reden von mittlerweile 15 Ländern, wir reden von zweieinhalb tausend Leuten in einem Konsortium,
wir haben einen Teil des deutschen Beitrags davon, finanziell nicht mal der
größte, funktional aktuell wahrscheinlich einer der wichtigsten,
aber das ist wirklich von ganz vielen Leuten gekommen aus sehr vielen Institutionen.
Wir haben Teile mit am Anfang mitentwickelt, wir haben Teile vom Kalibrationskonzept
entwickelt, was sehr zentral ist. Andere Leute haben ganz andere zentrale Sachen
gemacht. Datenverarbeitung zentral mit aufgebaut.
Also ich will jetzt nicht unsere Rolle … Ich wollte ja eher darauf hinaus,
dass sozusagen, also es gab wahrscheinlich gar nicht jetzt einmal diesen konkreten
Vorschlag, lass uns mal genau diese Mission machen, sondern man hat einfach
nur gesagt, das müsste man sich mal anschauen.
Und dann ist quasi in diesen ganzen Beratungssitzungen beschlossen worden,
guck mal hier, das passt doch irgendwie alles zusammen, können wir da nicht
die passenden Instrumente bauen, die quasi alles abdecken?
Und ich glaube in der Frühphase waren das keine Beratungssitzungen,
sondern Abendessen oder Kaffeeunterhaltung.
Und dann irgendwann wurde es formalisiert und im Prinzip wurde dann von der
ESA gesagt, okay wir machen eine sogenannte Phase A Studie, wo doch das mal
wirklich durchgerechnet werden soll.
Richtiges, vernünftiges optisches Konzept, mechanisches Konzept,
Datenverarbeitungskonzept, was für Detektoren bräuchte man da,
was für Optiken, welche Genauigkeiten in der Abbildung, wie groß muss so ein
Spiegel sein zum Beobachten, was Schwachheit von Galaxien angeht oder Auflösung.
Hängt immer zusammen, wie genau muss das sein, je genauer desto teurer was Optiken angeht,
wie viele Pixel brauchen wir auf den Detektoren, reicht da ein Detektor oder brauchen wir 100,
auch wieder 100 mal mehr kosten und so weiter und so weiter und dann kristallisierten sich,
kristallisierte sich dieses Optikkonzept raus mit einem 1,20 Meter Spiegel,
mit zwei Instrumenten, ein Instrument im optischen, mit einem einzigen Passband,
was jetzt WIS heißt, das im sichtbaren Licht operiert, was.
Ganz speziell für diesen schwachen Gravitationsnissen-Effekt zuständig ist,
wo im Prinzip die ganze Mission drum gebaut wurde,
dass die Fähigkeit von diesem Instrument Formen ganz, ganz exakt zu messen und
ganz, ganz niedrigen Fehlerraten oder ganz niedrigen Unsicherheiten zu messen,
dass das sozusagen über allem anderen steht.
Ja das ist ganz wichtig, ich muss, wie ich gesagt habe, ich muss von außen die
Form des Mondes von der Erde unterscheiden, in erster Linie alles rund,
aber halt nicht indem ich so groß auf den Mond gucke, sondern indem ich irgendwie
10 Pixel darüber hab oder 5 Pixel.
Aber dieser Linseneffekt der müsste doch eigentlich auch genauso im Infrarotbereich
zu sehen sein, gerade bei den alten. Was könnte man machen?
Infrarot ist teurer als optisch. Zwei Sachen. Erstens ist es teurer.
Ich kann, ich hab hier ein, das WISS Instrument hat 36 CCD Detektoren,
jeweils 4 mal 4000 Pixeln.
Das sind so und so wie Megapixel. Riesig groß, sehr fein.
Das Ganze in der Auflösung im Nahinfraroten zu machen würde sehr viel mehr kosten,
weil die Infrarot Detektoren sehr viel teurer sind.
Geht einem dann nicht sozusagen was verloren, weil man gar nicht so tief in
die Vergangenheit schauen kann, weil umso älter die sind, umso mehr sind die doch rot verschoben.
Ja das macht aber nichts, die haben ja immer noch eine Form.
Dann sehen wir halt ursprünglich dieses UV-Licht.
Ah. So.
Also wir gucken auch nicht besonders im Blauen, wir gucken schon im Roten,
wir gucken irgendwo zwischen Grün und etwas röter als wir sehen können oder
deutlich röter als wir sehen können.
Verstehe. Man muss nicht alles sehen, man muss irgendwas sehen und das kann
sich auch genauso gut aus dem Ultravioletten reinschieben.
Genau, und wir nehmen schon den Bereich, der wirklich dem roten,
sichtbaren Licht entspricht.
Gerade so CCD-Detektoren, die da günstiger, Anführungsstrichen,
nicht billig, aber günstiger sind, die hören bei ungefähr einem Mikrometer auf
in der Empfindlichkeit und wir gehen halt wirklich bis 0,92 Mikrometer ran.
So, das heißt wir gehen schon so rot wie es möglich ist, genau um diesen Effekt
nicht zu haben, dass wir zu viel Licht verlieren oder dass wir nur knotige Sternentstehungsgebiete
oder so sehen und das passt sehr gut mit der Entfernung zusammen,
die wir uns angucken wollen.
Zum anderen, wenn ich ins Infrarote gehe, die Auflösungsfähigkeit eines Teleskops
hängt von der Wellenlänge ab. Das heißt, wenn ich doppelt so lange Wellenlänge
habe, dann kann ich nur halb so gut auflösen.
Das heißt, wenn ich sage, ich muss Strukturen dieser und jener Größe auflösen,
und das geht mit einem Meter-zwanzig-Teleskop im Durchmesser bei 0,8 Mikrometern ganz gut.
Wenn ich sage, ja, ich würde das doch vielleicht lieber bei 1,6 Mikrometern
machen, dann bräuchte ich für dieselbe Winkelauflösung einen doppelt so großen Spiegel.
Und doppelt so großer Spiegel ist dann schon Hubble, das wird dann sehr,
sehr viel teurer. Das heißt, alles eine Abwägung.
Was brauche ich? Was muss ich messen? In welcher Genauigkeit?
In wie schwach dürfen die Galaxien sein?
Das ergibt sozusagen die Wellenlänge, mit der ich gehen kann.
Dann muss ich gucken, wie genau muss ich messen, wie groß, wie gut muss ich auflösen.
Okay, roter sichtbarer Wellenlängenbereich geht noch. Das heißt,
ich kann es mit CCDs machen und der Spiegel kann 1,20 m groß sein.
Und dann wurde passend dazu gerechnet, okay,
auf der anderen Seite, das zweite Instrument, an dem wir auch stärker beteiligt
sind, im Nahinfrarotbereich, ein bis zwei Mikrometern ungefähr,
Er soll sowohl Bilder machen, als auch Spektren aufnehmen, also Licht in die Wellenlängen zerlegt.
Gibt uns, wenn wir Emissionslinien haben von Galaxien, die eine bestimmte Wellenlänge
haben, sagt uns sofort sehr, sehr genau, in welcher Entfernung die Galaxien sich befinden.
Wenn ich irgendwas in seine Wellenlänge zerlege, kann ich nicht ganz so schwache
Objekte angucken, weil das Licht nicht mehr auf einem Punkt ist,
sondern auseinandergezogen ist. Da muss ich dann auch wieder rechnen,
wie viele Objekte brauche ich.
Weniger als ich beim schwachen Gravitationslinsen-Diagnostik angucken kann.
Dann passt das zusammen, geht das mit dem Spiegel und so weiter.
Und das alles wurde dann mit einer Architektur für zwei Instrumente und Anzahl
von Detektoren und Datenverarbeitung und Datenraten und Spiegelgröße und Temperaturen
und so wurde in eine Ursprungsstudie, Phase A, gegossen.
Und ESA fand das gut und dann irgendwann gabs glaub ich drei davon zur Auswahl
für einen bestimmten Start- und Entwicklungsplatz sag ich mal in der Reihenfolge
von den Missionen die ESA geplant hatte und dann haben sie gesagt okay 2011
wir nehmen als nächstes Euclid.
Und dann wurde es etwas weiterentwickelt und 2012 wurde es dann zur echten Mission
und da hat sicherlich geholfen dass es 2011 einen Nobelpreis für Dunkle Energie gab.
Passte, zufälligerweise.
Es war sozusagen Zeit, also da wurde da im Prinzip dieser Effekt ausgezeichnet
und als diese Ankündigung kam,
für mich war da ziemlich klar, dass Euclid dann ausgewählt wird,
da kann die Isa, wenn sie im Prinzip freie Wahl hat, nicht drum rum und so war
das dann auch, die anderen Missionen sind dann auch im Laufe der Zeit angenommen worden.
Und seit 2012 ging es dann sozusagen ans Eingemachte.
Wurde gesagt, so jetzt plant mal exakt und genau und dann gibt es die exakte Verteilung,
welche Institute und welche Länder können wie viel Geld für welche Teile bereitstellen,
weil die Teleskop- und Weltraumfahrzeug, sage ich mal, zahlt die ESA,
die beiden Instrumente stammen von Institutskonsortien über Europa verteilt
mit Beiträgen von der NASA.
Und auch unter Beteiligung des MPE?
Auch unter Beteiligung des MPE. Die deutschen Beiträge für die Hardware wurden
vom DLR bezahlt, unserer Raumfahrtagentur.
Also es geht jenseits der finanziellen Mittel einzelner Institute, sage ich mal.
Im Max-Planck-Institut für extraterrestrische Physik in Garching wurde die Optik
für dieses Na-Infrarot-Instrument entwickelt.
Wir haben eine Kalibrationslampe beigetragen, wir haben Infrarot-Filter beigetragen,
die wir dann mit Industrie zusammen entwickelt haben.
Hat fünf Jahre gedauert, das Ganze hinzukriegen, gut sechs, sieben,
bis das dann alles fertig geschnitten, gemacht, getestet und so weiter war.
Und parallel haben wir funktionale Sachen beigetragen, nämlich von Anfang an
ein Kalibrationskonzept.
Kalibration heißt, es ist toll, wenn wir was messen und dann haben wir da ein Bild,
aber wenn wir nicht wissen, was das bedeutet, weil nämlich wir nicht wissen,
ob da irgendwelche systematischen Helligkeitsschwankungen drin sind oder ob
die Verzerrung so und so größer ist als geplant, dann hilft uns ein Datenpunkt gar nicht.
Das heißt, ein Datenpunkt hilft einem immer nur was, wenn man einen Fehlerbalken da dran hat.
Und da wir wussten, wo wir hinwollen an Unsicherheiten,
was wir maximal tolerieren können für die Kosmologie, wurde das häppchenweise
runtergebrochen auf Dinge, die wir im Himmel angucken müssen,
Dinge, die das Instrument können muss und die Genauigkeit, mit denen wir jeden
einzelnen Parameter auf dem Bild dann hinterher messen können wollen.
Das ist ein garantisches Dokument und das haben wir im Prinzip anfänglich federführend
für unser Instrument gemacht und jetzt haben wir auch die koordinierende Oberhoheit,
die ganzen Teilnehmenden, die alle irgendwas mit Kalibration zu tun haben, zu koordinieren.
Und das machen wir seit 12 Jahren hier am Institut.
Also um es zusammen zu fassen, Euclid ist ein Raumfahrzeug, was im Wesentlichen
erstmal dieses Teleskop hat, ein Korsch Teleskop ist das, also im Prinzip genauso
aufgebaut wie das beim JWST auch, beim James Webb, so rein.
Ist das auch ein Korsch? Also es ist ein etwas off-axis Instrument,
wo der Strahl nicht immer durch
die Mitte geht, was sehr interessante Nebeneffekte beim Konstruieren hat.
Aber letztendlich, wir haben einen Spiegel, Primärspiegel, Sekundärspiegel,
Licht geht durch, wird irgendwann umgelenkt, dann einmal geteilt in den sichtbaren
Wellenlängenbereich und den infraroten und geht in die beiden Instrumente.
Genau und das eine ist eben das VIS, das andere ist das NISP, schön benannt immer.
NISP steht für Near-Infrared Spectrometer und Photometer, also Nahinfrarot-Spektrometer und Photometer.
Und da gibt es die zwei Kanäle, nämlich den Photometer-Bereich,
der tatsächlich Bilder macht, und der Spektrometer-Bereich, der Spektren aufnimmt.
Und dafür haben wir aus der Entwicklung her unterschiedliche Verantwortlichkeiten,
weil die Detektoren sind dieselben und die Optik am Anfang ist dieselben.
Aber was mit den Daten passieren muss...
Wurden auf der einen Seite Gitter gebaut,
mit horrenden Anforderungen, das haben unsere französischen Kollegen zum Glück gemacht,
was mit den Daten dann passieren wird, das geht in die eine Diagnostik rein
und dann gibt's den Photometer-Bereich, den P-Bereich, das sind wir,
wofür wir etwas stärker verantwortlich sind.
Da geht's um Bilder und diese Bilder werden mit bodengebundenen Bildern kombiniert,
um dann grobe Entfernungen für diesen schwachen Gravitationslinseneffekt zu erzeugen.
Und das war's im Prinzip. Eine relativ überschaubare Geschichte.
Nicht so ein Koloss mit neun verschiedenen Instrumenten, die dann alle funktionieren müssen.
Deswegen ist Euclid eigentlich auch kein Observatorium. Euclid ist eigentlich
viel dichter an einem Experiment dran als an einer Sternwarte.
Weil bei uns gibt es keine Programme, die man vorschlagen kann,
wo man sagen kann, ich würde gerne dieses und jenes Objekt angucken.
Es gibt auch keine Einzelobjekte, die angeguckt werden. Wir machen eine Himmelsdurchmusterung
mit einem ganz klaren Ziel.
Und wenn man mit den Daten noch was anderes machen kann, ist gut.
Und das machen ganz viele, wie ich gesagt habe. Aber das Ziel ist eine ganz
einfache Himmelsdurchmusterung.
Wir gehen wirklich zu jedem Punkt im Himmel, den wir angucken wollen.
Machen dort vier Bilder mit leichten Verschiebungen der Positionierung für bessere Datenverarbeitung.
Und dann gehen wir zum nächsten Feld.
Wir machen das gleich nochmal nach einer Stunde, 15 Minuten,
dann gehen wir zum nächsten Feld und so weiter und so weiter und das über sechs Jahre.
Okay, lass uns da gleich mal drauf kommen. Ich wollte jetzt erstmal mal ein
bisschen das Raumfahrzeug erst mal starten lassen.
Ach stimmt, das sollte man ja auch noch machen nach der Planung.
Also gebaut wurde es glaube ich von Astrium und also das Nutzlastmodul und dann der Rest von Thales.
Das ist alles. Die beiden zwei der großen militärisch-industriellen Raumfahrtunternehmen
in Europa, die können das.
Die konnten die Optik und die Spiegel wurden dann hergestellt und Kommunikation
und so weiter und so weiter.
Und das war dann Juli 2020 fertig und sollte ja eigentlich dann 2022 mit einer
Sojus-Rakete in Kourou starten.
Sojus ist ja eigentlich eine relativ junge Hinzufügung in Kourou gewesen,
wo ja klassischerweise immer die Ariane-Raketen starten und dann kam ja dann
in den letzten Jahren mit der italienischen Vega kleinen Rakete und eben den
russischen Sojus-Raketen weitere Launch-Positionen mit dazu. Aber dann gab's Krieg.
Genau, also es war schon seit ein paar Jahren gab es immer eine Backup-Lösung,
die Europäer hätten gerne ihre Ariane 6 benutzt und es war ganz klar,
wenn die Ariane 6 schnell fertig würde, was halt 2017, 18 oder so einfach ganz
unklar war, dann würden wir tatsächlich mit der Ariane 6 fliegen.
Also wenn die zeitnah fertig geworden wäre, dann wäre sozusagen Sojus-Backup
geworden. Ja und dann hat Russland die Ukraine überfallen und da war von Tag
eins klar, nö, ist nicht.
Egal wie sich das hier entwickelt, ist nicht machbar, wird nicht passieren.
Und ab dem Punkt war eigentlich die Ariane 6.
Der Hauptlauncher oder der geplante.
Und das war gut, dass wir sozusagen einen Backup gleich hatten.
Wir mussten sozusagen nicht von Anfang an testen.
Also Backup heißt ja konkret, man hat das von vornherein so geplant,
dass es im Prinzip sowohl die eine als auch die andere Rakete hätte transportieren
können, weil das ist ja jetzt auch nicht so beliebig ohne weiteres austauschbar.
Genau, es ist nicht beliebig austauschbar, vor allen Dingen,
reingepasst, also Euklid ist viereinhalb Meter hoch und irgendwie drei Meter im Durchmesser und so,
oder 280 im Durchmesser in jede Richtung, das heißt es ist groß,
aber nicht exorbitant groß, das heißt viele der Großraketen würden damit problemfrei zurechtkommen.
Und es ist auch, mit zwei Tonnen ist es jetzt auch nicht, also JWST hatte nur
eine Möglichkeit, das war die Ariane 5, so, und ansonsten gab es irgendwie keine Möglichkeit.
Es hätten mehrere in Frage kommen können, aber es war immer eine politische
Frage, wenn natürlich Ariane 6 fertig ist, dann nimmt man die.
Man plant also gleichzeitig für zwei Varianten und das hat großen Auswirkungen
darauf, denn je nachdem was man für ein System hat, kommen zum Beispiel mehr
Vibrationen in das Teleskop oder die Nutzlast rein.
Wir haben ganz klar das Problem, ganz, ganz viele der Konstruktionssachen finden
nur statt für zwei Minuten beim Start,
weil wir dort, wie man es dann halt auch aus zehn oder zwanzig Kilometern hört,
extreme Lautstärke haben, Lautstärke heißt Vibration, womit wir wieder bei den
akustischen Oszillationen werden, aber ganz andere.
Und das muss es halt aushalten, da dürfen keine Sachen abbrechen,
da dürfen keine Linsen zerspringen oder so.
Und die Ariane 6 hatte ganz klar,
die hat Feststoffbooster glaube ich, und Feststoffbooster habe ich gelernt machen
deutlich mehr Vibrationen als wenn man nur flüssig Antrieb hat und entsprechend
war am Anfang nicht klar,
ob die Ariane 6 das starten könnte oder ob sie über die geplanten Vibrationen
hinweg geht und dann wurde gesagt, okay wir brauchen noch irgendwelche Dämpfer
oder sowas, die da eingebaut werden müssen. Aber das war mehrere Jahre in Entwicklung.
Und wäre die fertig geworden frühzeitig, dann wäre das auch sozusagen gesagt,
okay gut, den Vertrag mit der Sojus, den nutzen wir für irgendwas anderes,
wir machen dann unser Prestige, neue Rakete.
Wurde aber natürlich gesagt, wir versuchen mal nicht der erste Start zu sein,
sondern wir müssen mindestens zwei erfolgreich sein, denn gebranntes Kind schallt
das Feuer und neue Raketen sind immer nicht gut für.
Erste Ariane 5 Start ist ja auch in die Hose gegangen.
Genau und das war auch unabhängig davon zu sagen,
also man das ist zu wertvoll, ist so speziell, das ist jetzt nicht einfach ein
weiterer von 10 Satelliten, den man hochschießt und dann nimmt man halt einen
weiteren oder so, sondern es ist halt sehr viel individuelle Arbeit,
der dann auch nicht einfach so rekonstruierbar ist.
Und als dann der Krieg angefangen wurde, da war klar ist vorbei und Ariane 6
würde der Hauptlauncher sein und da,
Fragte man sich dann relativ bald, okay an welcher, erstens wann wird die fertig,
zweitens an welcher, auf welchem Launchplatz wären wir.
Und dann kam das also verschiedene andere Auftraggeber weltweit sagten,
ach wir hätten gerne auch noch ein paar Startplätze, wir würden gerne für unsere
kommerziellen Sachen würden wir gerne mal testen, ob das mit einer Ariane 6 geht.
Und dann waren wir plötzlich nicht mehr auf Startplatz 4, sondern auf Startplatz
5 und dann gab's die große Frage, okay, also wenn das einmal passiert,
dass man nach hinten gereicht wird, dann kann das auch mehrfach passieren, das geht nicht.
Und Ariane 6 ist ja bis jetzt noch nicht gestartet.
Unabhängig davon, unabhängig davon, es war nicht so, dass jetzt klar war,
in einem Jahr starten wir und zwar garantiert, so das wäre überhaupt gar kein Problem gewesen.
Und dann hat sich tatsächlich die ESA umgeschaut und hat gesagt,
okay was gibt's denn an anderen Optionen und hat innerhalb von kürzester Zeit tatsächlich gesagt,
okay SpaceX ist flexibel, hat die Kapazität,
es würde passen, Studien gemacht, ob das FIP von den Liberationen funktionieren
würde und innerhalb von wenigen Monaten kam dann der Vorschlag mit einer Fake
9 zu starten und politisch ist das tatsächlich dann auch durchgegangen.
Weil es ist natürlich was Großpolitisches.
Plötzlich eine europäische Rakete soll und wird und muss und so weiter und dann
geht man plötzlich zu den Amerikanern, zu den kommerziellen Anbietern,
die eigentlich eine Konkurrenz sind und startet.
Aber es wurde verstanden, was es ansonsten wissenschaftlich bedeutet.
Es wurde verstanden, dass das auch nichts gegen die Ariane 6 sagt,
denn die war einfach noch nicht fertig.
Es ging dann ratzfatz sehr schnell, Leute im Konsortium mussten verstehen,
dass wir nicht jetzt plötzlich länger Zeit haben, sondern dass wir mit am Anfang
dieses Quartal 3 2023 starten würden, dann hieß es irgendwann Juli und
dann hieß es okay, es kann am ersten Juli losgehen und es war dann erst der Juli, so.
Also die NASA war ja beteiligt, also jetzt nicht im großen Maße,
wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Sie haben, glaube ich, Sensoren beigetragen und damit ist aber dann sozusagen
auch eine wissenschaftliche Beteiligung da dann auch mit verbunden,
insofern passt das ja noch.
Ja, aber die Verträge sind nicht über die NASA gelaufen. Das ist kein NASA-Vertrag,
das ist ein ESA-Vertrag, direkt ein SpaceX.
NASA hat da keinerlei Finger drin gehabt, sondern das war direkt,
auch der Launch selber war über.
Man muss ja dann auch irgendwann einfach mal, man kann ja so eine Mission nicht
ewig in die Länge ziehen,
also wenn es nicht anders geht, dann geht es halt nicht anders,
aber Wissenschaftler arbeiten da dran, sind ja auch für so und so viele Jahre
dann finanziert und wenn es dann halt nochmal länger dauert,
dann ist dann am Ende keiner mehr da, der sich darum kümmern kann.
Und auch bei der ESA selber ist ja klar, die haben so und so viele laufende
Missionen und sie können,
haben auch nicht beliebig viel Personal und irgendwann will das Personal auch
mal fertig sein mit einer Mission und die soll dann laufen,
also das Entwicklungspersonal, die ganzen Projektmanager, IngenieurInnen,
die daran gearbeitet haben, die müssen halt auch irgendwann mal andere Sachen
machen und wenn sich das über zwei Jahre hinwegzieht, dann verliert man irgendwann
die Expertise und dann ist so eine Mission auch irgendwann ernsthaft gefährdet.
Und das war zum Glück nicht der Fall, wir sind gestartet, alles glatt gelaufen,
Lagrange Sprung 2 zum ersten Mal für SpaceX, dass die dort hin geflogen sind.
Und jetzt, ja, paar Wochen später war Euclid dann in der...
Nähe von JWS2 und Gaia.
Lass uns da erstmal hinkommen, weil ist ja noch ein bisschen vorher was passiert,
also jetzt Juli 23, wir nehmen jetzt die Sendung hier auf am 23.
Oktober 23, also ist das ganze jetzt vier, fünf Monate her.
Ganz problemlos war's nicht, also der Start war super.
Der Start war super, ein paar Tage später wurden die Instrumente eingeschaltet,
alles funktionierte hervorragend, die waren, kühlten ab,
es wurde minimalste Orbitkorrektur gemacht,
war wirklich sehr genau der, die Injektion in den Orbit, was uns auch Treibstoff
spart, das heißt potenziell steht er dann später zur Verfügung für längere Mission,
was gut ist, wir hatten's gehofft.
Das ist ja ein nicht unerheblicher Faktor, weil wenn jetzt die Bahn nicht gut
angeschossen wird und man muss halt korrigieren,
das ist ganz schön teuer, das frisst eine Menge Sprit im Vergleich zu dem,
was man mit dem Sprit machen könnte mit leichten Bahnkorrekturen.
Genau, denn Lagrange Punkt 2 ist kein stabiler Punkt, das ist ein halbstabiler
Punkt und das heißt es muss jeden Monat eine kleine Bahnkorrektur geben,
um den Satelliten da wieder zurückzuschubsen und das ist derselbe Treibstoff,
der auch für eine Orbitkorrektur nach dem Start benutzt worden wäre.
Wenn der alle ist, ist er alle. Da fliegt keiner hin und füllt nach.
Und diese Orbitkorrekturen sind einer der limitierenden Faktoren für die Länge
der Mission. Und das wäre natürlich blöd, wenn das frühzeitig alle wäre.
Und in diesem Fall war es weniger benutzt worden als geplant und das ist positiv.
Und die Instrumente konnten auch problemlos in Betrieb genommen werden?
Die Instrumente funktionieren hervorragend von Anfang an. Wir haben die ersten
Bilder gesehen, alles ganz klasse.
Dann gab es eine Fokussierungskampagne des Teleskops, die Instrumente gegeneinander
haben alle einen fixen Fokus.
Es gibt nur genau ein Element beim Sekundärspiegel, wo alles auf einmal fokussiert
wird und das hat auch relativ bald funktioniert.
Hat eine Woche gedauert, Woche drei oder sowas nach dem Start.
Und danach war im Prinzip...
Wir hatten immer irgendwie Probleme mit Streulicht irgendwie in irgendeiner Form.
Ja genau, also das waren erstmal die Instrumente. Die Instrumente funktionieren
absolut hervorragend. Die besser als wir erwartet haben.
Also in dem Rahmen wie man erwarten könnte, dass sie etwas besser funktionieren
als man hofft. So, als sie minimal funktionieren mussten. Klasse.
Kommandierung funktioniert, Datenübertragung funktioniert, Aufnahmen funktionieren.
Da fehlt einem schon mal ein Stein vom Herzen.
Und erstens, dass da keine Schlitter durch die Gegend fliegen,
von irgendwelchen Linsen, und zweitens, dass die Detektoren so funktionieren, wie sie sollen.
Dann gab's so ein paar Kleinigkeiten, sag ich mal, die uns jeweils ein bisschen
in Atem gehalten haben. Es gab Streulicht, was wir irgendwie gesehen haben, was...
Irgendwie durch die Isolierung kommt,
die ja eine Lichtisolierung ist, aber die Instrumente sitzen nicht in einem
Karton, die sitzen auf einer Plattform und wenn man an der Seite diese goldene
Isolierung einfach abwickeln würde, dann wären die da offen drin.
So, natürlich auch einem Licht ausgesetzt.
Eigentlich hinter einem Lichtschild. Die Solarzellen gucken immer zur Sonne
und die haben so ein bisschen noch Flügel an der Seite und eigentlich ist das
immer dieselbe Richtung und eigentlich ist das Instrument im Schatten.
So, und wenn an den Kanten nichts reflektiert wird, dann ist das Schatten-Schatten und dann so.
Dann hat man halt noch goldene Multi-Layer-Installationen da drum rumgewickelt,
für Thermostabilisierung, aber auch ein bisschen für die Lichtdichtheit und
dann stellt er sich raus,
es gibt irgendwo einen Punkt außerhalb dieses Schildes, wo Licht drauf fällt
von der Sonne und der strahlt dann halt einfach von der falschen Seite, ist hell.
Und die Sonne hat halt einfach den sehr sehr unangenehmen Teil für so einen
sehr empfindlichen Satelliten, die ist sehr hell.
Und wenn wir halt hier Sonnenbrand kriegen oder 1000 Watt pro Quadratmeter.
Also ist das ein Designfehler gewesen?
Das ist, ich glaube das war ein, das kann ich nicht genau sagen,
das würde ich auf die ESA verweisen, ich glaube es gab relativ spät noch eine
Veränderung von einem Booster oder sowas, der irgendwie ein bisschen versetzt wurde.
Ich weiß nicht genau, ob das der war, der dann auch im Licht war.
Jedenfalls hätte diese Isolierung nicht auch zufällig mit mehreren internen
Reflektionen einen Pfad gehabt, wo Licht durch kann.
Und da reden wir auch nicht von einem Loch, sondern wir reden von viel,
viel, viel Dämpfung durch mehrere Reflektionen, wo immer nur ein Zehntel Prozent oder so durchkommt.
Aber Sonne gegenüber ein Instrument, was halt irgendwie eine Kerze in weiß nicht
wie viel Entfernung sehen kann.
Das ist halt blöd. So und das passierte und dann stellte sich aber relativ bald
raus, wir haben einen gewissen Winkel, den dieses Sonnenschild zur Sonne haben kann.
Wir können das Teleskop in drei Teilen, drei Winkeln, drei Achsen drehen.
Die eine Achse ist die, die wir immer benutzen, wo immer die,
also man zieht die Achse zur Sonne und die können wir immer rumgehen und beobachten.
Und in den anderen beiden Achsen haben wir ein bisschen Spielraum,
um halt den Himmel ein bisschen abzudecken über ein paar Grad in eine Richtung
oder die andere Richtung.
Und da stellt er sich relativ bald raus, okay, in der Achse,
wo das beleuchtet wird, wenn wir das Teleskop da ein bisschen rausdrehen und sozusagen unseren,
nicht um Null, Winkel Null Grad beobachten werden, sondern um Winkel minus zweieinhalb
Grad oder sowas oder minus fünf Grad oder sowas, also wirklich nur fünf Grad
gedreht, dann passt das auf beiden Seiten.
Wir haben immer noch nicht mehr ganz so viel Flexibilität beim Survey,
deswegen musste auch neu geplant werden,
aber es funktioniert und dann ist dieser Booster oder dieses Stück,
was da im Licht hängt, ist aus dem Licht raus, kann nicht mehr reflektieren,
Haken dran, alles was ansonsten streulicht ist, ist minimal und handhabbar.
Das heißt dadurch hatte man einen etwas geringeren Survey-Bereich,
den man so in einem Schritt aufnehmen konnte?
Ja im Prinzip die Auswahl zu jedem Zeitpunkt,
welchen Bereich am Himmel man zu jedem Zeitpunkt angucken kann,
schrumpfte etwas und das heißt wir müssen im Prinzip diese Himmelsdurchmusterung,
die für sechseinhalb Jahre auf die Minute durchgetaktet ist,
also es gibt natürlich einen Plan, wann muss was angeguckt werden,
wo geht man von einem Feld zum nächsten, wie lange sind die Beobachtungen,
was für Kalibrationen muss wann aufgenommen werden, das muss jetzt umgeplant
werden, wird umgeplant und es war ziemlich schnell klar, das ist handhabbar.
Und das andere war, dass wir festgestellt haben, dass wir ein schönes Röntgenteleskop haben.
Denn es gab irgendwo ein Loch in der Abschottung.
Wenn die Sonne gerade extrem aktiv ist bei einem Sonnenflare,
dann macht sie extra viel Röntgenstrahlung und dann gibt es ein paar Winkel.
Wenn das Teleskop gerade so steht zur Sonne, dann kriegen wir im Prinzip röntgenlicht,
was durch unsere Isolation durchgeht und macht auf dem einen,
dann macht auch der Detektor was.
Und da ist jetzt aber auch klar, durch was für Löcher das durchgeht und es ist
klar, wann das auftritt. Die Sonne ist zwar jetzt besonders aktiv,
weil wir Richtung Sonnenmaximum gehen oder wenn wir im Sonnenmaximum sind,
aber es ist so hinreichend selten, dass man damit auch umgehen kann.
Und das sind so die typischen Sachen. Ich würde mal sagen, beide Dinge sind
so die typischen Sachen, die nach so einem Start auftreten, für die man nicht
plant. Weil alle Sachen, die wir abgesehen haben, sind natürlich erledigt.
Da findet man natürlich vorher Lösungen für. Und das sind so typische Dinge,
die man hinterher feststellt und wo man relativ flexibel dann was lösen muss.
Und das ist passiert und die Sicherheiten sind glaube ich wirklich gut unter
Kontrolle. Das tauchte auch in den ersten Tagen, bei den ersten Daten schon
auf und da war erstmal das Zähne klappern groß und jetzt ist das gelöst würde ich sagen.
So und Ziel war L2 erfahrenen Raumfahrern natürlich bekannt.
Ja L2 weiß man ja aber es ist vielleicht nochmal wertvoll das hier genauer zu
erklären warum dieser Ort ausgewählt wird. ist ja ein sehr populärer Platz für Weltraum-Teleskope.
James Webb fährt da rum, auch Planck und Herschel, also all diese ganzen Weltraum-Surveys
sind dort gewesen oder sind dort noch.
Warum? Weil dieser Lagrange-Punkt 2 ja einer von fünf Punkten ist,
wo sich die Gravitationswirkung der Erde und der Sonne so weit ausgleichen,
dass man eben nicht so ohne weiteres erstmal irgendwo hingezogen wird.
Das heißt da kann man ganz gut verweilen und vor allem mit der Erde um die Sonne
herumziehen und L2 ist ja der Punkt sozusagen hinter der Erde,
also von der Sonne aus gesehen, der eben dann auch dunkler ist,
kälter ist, weil man ist ja nochmal etwas weiter weg.
Ja, wobei die Entfernung spielt nicht so groß die Rolle. Auf jeden Fall ist er stabil.
Und das ist das Schöne, wir sind an einem Ort, der immer ungefähr gleich von
der Sonne entfernt ist, der auch ungefähr gleich von der Erde entfernt ist,
weil nämlich dann nicht irgendwie plötzlich Licht von einer reflektierten Erde
oder so von rechts oder links reinscheint.
Dauerhafte Entfernung, wenn wir ein Teleskop dort einfach hinstellen,
was mit dem Sonnenschild einfach in dieselbe Richtung guckt,
das ist einfach thermisch sehr stabil. Und thermisch sehr stabil heißt,
nichts dehnt sich mal aus, weil alle Materialien dehnen sich aus,
wenn sie die Temperatur ändern.
Und das heißt, wir haben ein System, wo sich die Mechanik nicht ausdehnt,
die Optik nicht verändert.
Das ist stabil. Wenn das im Fokus ist, bleibt das fokussiert.
Da fängt nicht an, plötzlich irgendwie der linke Rand aus dem Fokus raus zu wölben oder so.
Aber im Prinzip viele dieser Voraussetzungen hätte man ja auch an eins,
also das ist dann sozusagen zwischen Erde und Sonne, aber da hätte man zum Beispiel
schon mal die ganze Zeit die Erde im Blick, die da auch leuchtet.
Genau, dann hätte man die Erde im Blick.
Genau, das wäre blöd.
Das ist nicht so toll. Und dann gibt's noch die drei L4, die also vor und hinter
der Bahn der Erde liegen, die wären ja im Prinzip auch geeignet,
nur da tummeln sich dann so kleine Meteoriten und das ist nicht so schön.
L2 ist einfach ganz gut handhabbar. Das ist einfach weg.
Man kann Orbits sich dort nehmen, die auch, wo die Erde nicht vor der Sonne steht,
also keine kleinen Sonnenfinsternissen da sind, das ist für Gaia ganz wichtig,
das ist für JWST und Euklid sehr wichtig, weil auch so ein bisschen Abdeckung
würde bedeuten, dass irgendwie die Temperatur sich kurzzeitig ändert und die
Stromversorgung durch die Solarzellen sich ändert. Das heißt,
wir können dort Orbits haben, die,
Da bewegen sich die um das Zentrum oder den formalen Zentrum von L2 herum und
es ist alles sehr stabil.
Ich kann meine Antenne in eine Richtung richten und da wir da einen Millionen-Kilometer-Durchmesser
haben von L2, ist voll auch relativ.
Also sich da zufällig zu treffen, das wird schon navigationstechnisch schwierig,
wenn man das machen möchte.
Per Zufall stößt da nichts zusammen bei drei, vier, fünf Missionen.
So dann schauen wir aber doch nochmal da drauf wie das dann jetzt abläuft.
Also Euclid ist dann ich schätze mal so nach vier Wochen oder so dürfte das
Ding so alles in Betrieb gewesen sein, das heißt seit August,
sprich jetzt ungefähr für zwei Monate ist im Prinzip schon so ein Normalbetrieb
oder ist das sozusagen immer noch ein Testen?
Offiziell sollte, war der Plan, dass wir direkt nach dieser vier Wochen Hochfahrphase
eine sogenannte Performance Verification Phase machen,
wo im Prinzip einmal alle möglichen Kalibrationsdaten aufgenommen werden und geguckt wird,
kann das Teleskop was wir erwarten, auf dem Boden,
mit leicht anderen Temperaturen und so weiter und können wir alle Referenzdaten
aufnehmen für alle Detektoren,
Empfindlichkeitskarten und Dunkelstromkarten und was weiß ich,
also alles was so charakterisiert Alle besonderen Schmutzeffekte oder Effekte,
die dann in den Wissenschaftsdaten auch drin sein werden, die müssen wir alle
wieder rausholen und da nehmen wir dann nicht irgendwie Testdaten von der Erde, wie
wir im Labor gemacht haben, sondern dort wirklich vor Ort.
Ja und nach zwei, drei Tagen stellte sich irgendwie heraus, das war nicht so
einfach, denn das Teleskop hat seine Position nicht gehalten.
Wir haben natürlich da ein sehr komplexes System, was verschiedenste Dinge von
Gyroskopen und tatsächlichen Sensoren für den Ort der Sonne und feine Sensoren,
die tatsächlich Sterne verfolgen, die irgendwo sind und sagt ok,
wenn der ein bisschen raus wandert, dann gebe ich einen leichten Schub und gucke wieder nach links.
Und das hat so nicht funktioniert. Da gab es Signale, wo plötzlich Sterne verloren
wurden für dieses Guiding. Da gab es Signale, guck doch mal bitte,
ich glaube der Stern ist jetzt plötzlich drei Grad weg, guck mal da rüber.
Und so weiter und so weiter. Und es stellt sich fest, da gab es ein Softwareproblem
auf der Teleskop- und Systemseite.
Und wir haben im Prinzip 50% aller Aufnahmen verloren.
Und damit kann man nicht arbeiten. Und dann wurde gesagt, okay,
diese Phase beenden wir erstmal wieder.
Wir müssen zurück in die Commissioning-Phase. Es war auch klar,
dass diese Arbeiten noch nicht beendet waren,
aber es gab die Hoffnung, dass diese Commissioning-Phase für dieses Guiding-System
durch kleinere Fixes erfolgreich parallel gelöst werden könnte.
Und das war halt nicht richtig. Dann wurde gesagt, okay, das hat keinen Zweck
hier, wir vergolden nur ein paar Punkte.
Ja nicht nur das, vor allen Dingen da haben sich halt 100 Leute,
haben 24 Stunden am Tag irgendwie diese Daten angeguckt,
Wochenenden und sonst wie, das war nach der Vorbereitungszeit auf Dauer nicht
durchhaltbar und dann hat man gesagt, nee das hat keinen Zweck,
das ist auch alles für die Tonne irgendwie, okay wir gehen zurück.
Hat im Prinzip einen Monat gedauert oder sechs Wochen. Wurde ein Fix gemacht,
Software neu geschrieben, umgebaut.
Wo ist das geschehen?
Das war ein Industriepartner, Isa hat darüber mehr geschrieben in ihrem Blog.
Und das wurde hochgelinkt und dann gab es eine relativ komplexe Testkampagne
auch mit dem Konsortium zusammen,
wo wir gesagt haben, okay, wenn wir unsere Instrumente nutzen,
was können wir an relativ schnellen Diagnostiken machen, um zu gucken,
ob auf verschiedenen Zeitskalen dieses Guiding jetzt gut funktioniert.
Weil, während der Missionszeit, der sechs Jahre in der Zukunft,
wollen wir ja eigentlich die ganze Zeit nur gucken, es gibt so Housekeeping-Informationen,
so einen Strom von Daten, der sagt,
das Teleskop hat einen Lock auf dem Stern und das funktioniert alles und der
Offset davon war maximal so und so groß und so und so groß und alles ist in
Ordnung und so und so und wenn man die Sachen verfolgt,
kann man eigentlich sagen, alles klar, wir vertrauen dem, das ist innerhalb
der Parameter, das können wir automatisch abchecken, das läuft alles gut.
So, wir wussten zu dem Zeitpunkt nicht, ob wir diesen Sachen trauen können.
Und ESA wusste das auch nicht. Das heißt, wir brauchten eine unabhängige Bestätigung dafür.
Das heißt, wir haben geguckt, okay, wenn wir jetzt mit irgendeinem super special
Modus dieses WIS-Instrument laufen lassen, dann kann das tatsächlich bei bestimmten
Sachen im Millisekundenbereich auslesen. Und wenn wir das NISP-Instrument schnell
auslesen, dann können wir im Dreisekundenbereich auslesen.
Und dann können wir sozusagen auf verschiedenen Zeitskalen hier Sachen angucken.
Das wurde geplant, dann wurden die Beobachtungen geplant,
hochgelinkt, Daten genommen und ausgewertet und es stellte sich raus,
okay, mit diesem Fix ist fast alles beseitigt, zumindest das Hauptproblem ist
beseitigt und das Guiding ist auch so gut und ein paar Diagnostiken,
den können wir trauen, wenn die jetzt vom Teleskop runterkommen.
Das heißt, wir müssen nicht mehr unsere Daten extrem tief angucken und gucken,
ist da was faul, sondern wir können den Diagnostiken vom Teleskop trauen.
Und jetzt geht's nochmal ein ganz klein bisschen in die Feinheiten,
aber das war dann gelöst und dann wurde gesagt, okay wir fangen am ersten Oktober glaube ich oder 28.
September fing's an, dass wir wieder zurück in die Performance Verification
Phase gehen und seitdem machen wir im Prinzip den Teil der ab August stattfinden
sollte und da kommen einfach ganz tolle Daten runter und die zeigen,
dass das, das wird funktionieren. Das wird alles sehr gut funktionieren.
Das heißt, der Survey hat jetzt noch gar nicht so richtig angefangen zu diesem Zeitpunkt?
Der hat noch nicht angefangen. Wir werden aller Voraussicht nach noch...
Drei Wochen, vier Wochen Daten nehmen, so wie das aussieht, dann braucht es
noch ein bisschen, um das zu verarbeiten.
Aber es ist relativ klar, die Instrumente und das Teleskop tut,
was es soll, in der Qualität, wie es soll und wir müssen nur sicherstellen,
dass wir alle Daten in der Qualität bekommen, um das dann zu kalibrieren.
Ob dann die Verarbeitung dieser Kalibrationsdaten noch einen Monat extra dauert
ist dann erstmal egal, aber wir wissen, dass das funktioniert und dann passieren zwei Dinge.
Erstens wir steigen den Survey ein mit nochmal Spezialbeobachtungen,
die Sachen machen, aber im Prinzip ist das der Survey, der dann sechs Jahre läuft.
Zum anderen wird es die offizielle, wird es einen offiziellen Review geben und
die Übergabe im Prinzip von der Industrie an die ESA.
Das heißt, da wird gesagt, okay, diese Anforderung an die Industrie für Qualität
wurde abgehakt und diese und diese,
dann haben wir einen Katalog von, weiß ich nicht, 200 Stück und wir können absehen,
dass das alles so funktioniert und dass das alles abhakbar ist,
aber da müssen halt entsprechend Bilder analysiert und Parameter ausgerechnet
und Dokumente geschrieben werden, damit das hinterher auch recht sicher dann
in einem Review abhakbar ist.
Währenddessen fangen wir dann aber mit dem Survey an. Ich nehme an,
dass wir Mitte November oder so in den Survey einsteigen und dann kommen ab
Anfang Januar kommen dann Daten.
Jeden Tag kommen ganz viele Daten von sehr vielen hunderttausend und Millionen Galaxien jeden Tag.
Genau. Dann geht's los. Kommen wir nochmal zu dieser Beobachtung beziehungsweise
auch zu diesen Daten, die dann rausfallen.
Das Ding, also die Kamera haben wir ja schon besprochen, man braucht ja immer Solarpanels,
Sonne kommt von hinten, da kommt irgendwie der Strom an und durch diese ganzen
Isolierungen, die da dran sind, wird halt versucht den eigentlichen Teleskopbereich
so kalt wie dunkel wie irgendwie möglich zu halten.
Ja, dunkel und kühl in bestimmte Temperaturbereiche.
Weil wenn man Infrarot misst, misst man ja eigentlich Wärme und wenn man dann
irgendwie selber warm ist, ist es halt nicht so.
Und wir sind zum Glück nur im nahen Infrarotbereich, also wir müssen nicht zum
absoluten Nullpunkt wie im mittleren oder fernen Infraroten,
wie die Herschel und Planck und sowas, die mussten sehr sehr viel kälter gemacht werden.
Oder auch James Webb.
Oder auch James Webb in Teilen, genau. Und wir können ganz passiv kühlen,
es gibt so große Strahlungsradiatorenflächen, die einfach in den Weltraum gucken
und hinreichende Menge an Wärme abführen können.
Das passt schon.
Das passt, ja. Minus 140 Grad bei uns, Detektoren zum Beispiel.
So und jetzt ist ja das Ziel möglichst viel abzudecken, das heißt das Ding rotiert
dann irgendwie oder muss es gar nicht so viel rotieren?
Wir machen im Prinzip so eine Sache wir gehen zu einem Ort, also Gaia rotiert
ja und macht ja sehr dezidiert, macht ja eben beim rotieren Aufnahmen.
Wir machen das nicht, wir gucken zu einem Ort, bleiben dort stehen,
also bleiben in der Orientierung, machen ein Bild im Nahinfrarotbereich,
unsere Direktbilder sind 100 Sekunden ungefähr, drei verschiedene Passbänder
in drei verschiedenen Wellenlängen und dann gibt es einen zweiten Abschnitt, wo wir parallel.
Den Visible Imager für 560 Sekunden aufnehmen lassen und parallel im Nahinfrarot
unsere Spektren, also im Spektroskopiebereich.
Die laufen parallel, 560 Sekunden, dann verschieben wir unseren Blick am Himmel
ein ganz kleines bisschen,
nur um auf andere Pixel auf den Detektoren zu kommen, machen das Ganze nochmal,
machen das Ganze nochmal, vier Stück und nach eineinviertel Stunde ungefähr
oder eine Stunde und 20 Minuten gehen wir zum nächsten Feld.
Und unser Gesichtsfeld, das Gesichtsfeld von Euclid ist so groß,
dass wir ein halbes Quadratgrad da drin haben. Das heißt es ist viermal ungefähr
die Fläche vom Mond, dreimal ungefähr die Fläche vom Mond, die wir da auf einmal
abbilden können insgesamt.
Das ist groß, das ist viel viel viel mehr als, wie gesagt, Hubble oder JWST
und das bedeutet, dass wir dann sichtbar am Himmel uns ein Stück zur Seite bewegen.
Und zwar zu jedem Zeitpunkt können wir halt, weil die Sonne immer im Rücken sein muss,
immer auf so einem Kreis, oben, links, rechts, unten gucken und pro Tag rotiert
das Ganze 360 Grad einmal rum,
365 Tage, also pro Tag rotiert Euclid mit der Erde im Prinzip um ungefähr einen
Grad rum und kann immer einen Grad weiter gucken.
Jetzt ist die Idee über sechs Jahre den Himmel dann so zusammen zu flicken,
dieses Drittel des Himmels,
was uns interessiert, wo die Hintergründe am niedrigsten sind,
Himmelshintergründe, wo es am dunkelsten ist, so zusammenzusetzen,
dass wir wirklich eine kontinuierliche Karte in Spektroskopie,
in Photometrie, im Nahinfraroten, in den drei Bändern und im sichtbaren Licht haben.
Das heißt, wir bekommen bis auf ein paar helle Sterne,
die wir umgehen, also im Prinzip alles, was man so mit bloßem Auge am Himmel sieht,
das umgehen wir, weil das zu hell ist, das brennt uns irgendwie nach Lichter
auf unsere Detektoren, aber alles andere über diesen Drittel des Himmels,
da gehen wir einfach Stück für Stück hin und machen jeweils eine Epoche Fotos.
Und dann geht das ein paar Stunden später an die Erde.
Und wie viel Daten fallen dann da konkret bei an? Also es wird ja alles genommen.
Man macht ja einen Full-Take, man will ja alles sehen. Oder gibt es in irgendeiner
Form noch eine Datenreduktion bevor das runtergesinnet wird,
was man nicht haben will?
Also die Wizz Bilder gehen einfach 1 zu 1 runter.
Die Datenmenge ist zwar viel, weil wir viele Pixel haben, aber wir machen nicht
alle 10 Sekunden ein Bild,
sondern wir machen alle 560 Sekunden, dann wartet es ein bisschen,
also wir machen lange Belichtungszeiten und haben im Prinzip 4 Bilder über eine
Stunde 20 Minuten. Das ist jetzt moderat.
Muss denn die Kamera justiert werden während dieser Belichtungszeit oder ist
das nicht erforderlich?
Einfach starr am Himmel. Einfach nur. Das Teleskop hält uns mit kleinen Kaltgasboostern
innerhalb von 75 Millibogensekunden an derselben Position.
Das heißt, dass wir beugungsbegrenzt sind, also dass das Bild des Teleskops
nicht verschlechtert wird. Dass es wirklich so gut wie es sein kann und der
Teleskop hält uns dort in der passenden Position.
Vom Nahinfrarotmodus, was wir am liebsten gehabt hätten, ist das, was Hubble kann.
Hubble könnte, also die Infrarotdetektoren werden kontinuierlich ausgelesen,
alle 1,4 Sekunden werden die ausgelesen und am liebsten hätten wir jedes dieser
Bilder. Aber das wäre zu viel.
Hubble macht das, Hubble kann das teilweise. Bei uns passiert das nicht.
Wir rechnen im Prinzip aus diesen ganzen Einzelauslesungen ein Bild für Photometrie
nach 100 Sekunden oder so, für Spektroskopie nach 560 Sekunden.
60 Sekunden und schicken das zur Erde zurück mit ein paar Qualitätssachen.
Also auch das sind im Prinzip moderate Datenmengen.
Wenn man halt nicht am Lagrange Punkt 2 wäre, für Lagrange Punkt 2 ist das schon
recht viel, wir brauchen dann wirklich 2x4 Stunden Downlink-Zeit am Tag für
die verschiedenen Antennen der ESA.
Ich kann nicht sagen, wie viele Petabyte das insgesamt sind.
Es ist keine extrem große Datenmenge.
Also wenn ich das mit CERN oder mit dem LSST-Survey vergleiche,
der dann kommen wird, das sind keine exorbitanten Datenmengen,
weil wir halt vier Bilder und nicht in Zehntelsekunden oder sowas machen. Es ist verarbeitbar.
Was dann auf der Erde passiert ist allerdings, dass wir relativ viel Software
im Hintergrund haben, weil wir halt zu diesen kosmologischen Parametern müssen.
Wir wollen dunkle Energie eingrenzen.
Da ist ein Parameter, der muss dann auf so und so genau gemessen werden und
das heißt, wir kommen von dieser sechseinhalb Jahren, also wenn man es ganz
platt sagen will, wir kommen von sechseinhalb Jahren Datennahme mit einem Bild
alle paar Minuten kommen wir auf zwei Zahlen.
Also das ist natürlich Datenreduktion at its best, weil das ist sozusagen das
Ziel dieses kosmologischen Experiments.
Also zwei Zahlen, eine Zahl für die dunkle Materie und eine für die inekte.
Ja im Prinzip zwei für die dunkle Materie mit Zeitfaktor und da spielt natürlich
viel mehr dahinter, das ist natürlich komplexer.
Aber letztendlich gibt's eine sehr große Kaskade an Eichung und an Bildbearbeitung,
was Astrometrie angeht, also die Positionierung und Verzerrung,
was Flachheit der Helligkeitsdaten angeht, also dass nicht 1000 Counts auf der
linken Seite nicht demgleichen entspricht wie 1000 Counts auf der rechten Seite.
Kalibrationssachen, um die Formen genau zu nehmen, da müssen wir noch die bei
dem WISS Instrument, wir müssen wissen, welche Farben die Galaxien haben,
weil unterschiedliche Farben sind unterschiedliche Wellenlängen,
unterschiedliche Wellenlängen haben unterschiedliche große Abbildungsfunktionen
und so weiter und so weiter.
Also es ist extrem viel Aufwand dahinter, deswegen ist die Datenreduktionskaskade
deutlich aufwendiger, als wenn ich nur ein schönes Bild in Anführungsstrichen
mal so einfach gesagt erzeugen will.
Und dafür arbeiten im Prinzip, ich weiß nicht, wie viele zig oder hundert Leute
seit auch zehn Jahren, um diese Kaskade von Pixeln bis hin zu kosmologischen
Parametern zu erzeugen.
Und auf der anderen Seite, damit wir das nämlich simulieren konnten,
nochmal so eine genauso große Seite, auf der anderen Seite, wo wir kosmologische
Simulationen gemacht haben, die dann in Bilddaten umgesetzt wurden,
die dann in Pixeldaten umgesetzt wurden mit allen Schmutzeffekten,
die dann der Input waren für die Datenreduktionsseite.
Um einmal komplett im Kreis von bekannten kosmologischen Einprägungen am Himmel
zu pixeln und dann zur Extraktion dieser Sachen wieder zu kommen.
Und das ist ein extrem großer Aufwand und das unterscheidet auch...
Sowohl von einem normalen Teleskop als auch von allen, ich glaube,
allen anderen Weltraummissionen, weil wir im Prinzip diesen Teil vorher fertig haben mussten.
Es ist nicht so, dass wir sagen können, okay, wenn die Instrumente jetzt etwas
schlechter funktionieren oder unser Algorithmus zur Bestimmung von Formen halt
nicht so gut ist, dann kriegen wir halt nicht so tolle Sachen hinterher raus,
wir machen andere Projekte.
Nein, es gibt ein Ziel und das muss erreicht werden, ansonsten braucht man die
Mission nicht zu starten.
Und deswegen musste das vorher fertig sein. Und das war und ist weiterhin sehr
sehr aufwendig was die Software angeht.
Zehn Datenzentren über die Welt verteilt mit Spezialisierungen,
viele Leute, sehr viele Leute die an Processing Functions für diese und jene
Funktion sitzen und so weiter.
Und das Veröffentlichungsprinzip ist so ein bisschen glaube ich nach Gaia.
Habt ihr euch abgeguckt?
Es geht so, Gaja, also Veröffentlichung hier geht's, Frage nach Bilddaten oder
Daten allgemein, an wen geht das?
Im Prinzip gilt für alle ESA Missionen wie für NASA Missionen,
Daten müssen relativ bald der Welt zugänglich sein. Und zwar nicht,
ich behalte die mal privat oder die Isabel die privat, sondern geht an die Welt.
Finde ich vollkommen richtig. Es ist ein bisschen anders als bei Gaia,
weil nämlich die Instrumente von Institutionen und einzelnen Funding-Agencies
bezahlt wurden, da wurde gesagt, okay wir brauchen irgendwie so ein bisschen
Zeit und auch Rückzahlung dafür, dass Leute sich halt.
Also der exklusive Auswertungszeitraum.
Auswertungszeitraum. Und da wird gesagt, okay, ihr kriegt 14 Monate Vorsprung
für bestimmte Sachen, aber danach geht's an die Welt.
Und diese 14 Monate sind auch absolut notwendig, weil das bedeutet,
dass ein Wissenschaftler, der darin beteiligt ist, vielleicht einen Artikel schreiben kann.
Pro Person maximal. Und nicht mehr. So, da bleibt sehr, sehr viel übrig für
den Rest der Welt, was so...
Sonstige Fragestellungen angeht. Zugleich hat es den Vorteil,
dass, wenn Leute Wissenschaft damit machen, dass ganz viele sehr detaillierte
Fragen an die Daten gestellt werden und sehr viele Auswertungen gemacht werden,
die eigentlich nicht bei der Kosmologie gemacht werden und da werden alle möglichen
sehr feinen Effekte noch auftauchen, die vielleicht noch in den Daten drin sind.
Und das fließt alles sofort wieder in die Reduktionskaskade rein,
wo gesagt wird, ah, hier sehen wir irgendeine Korrelation von,
was weiß ich, Rauschen in irgendwelchen Spalten.
Ah, oh, interessant. Könnte das einen Einfluss auf unsere Kosmologiemessung haben.
Wir kalibrieren das Haus, machen ein extra Modul irgendwo und dann ist es weg.
Also solche Sachen sind sehr wichtig.
Also Kalibrieren nicht in den Instrumenten, sondern Kalibrieren in den Daten.
In den Daten. Weil die Instrumente machen was sie tun und es wird,
hinterher werden die Daten kalibriert. Und letztendlich läuft es dann so,
es wird drei Arten von Releases oder Veröffentlichungen geben.
Die Hauptreleases sind unsere Data Releases 1, 2, 3.
Die veröffentlichen im Jahre glaube ich Anfang 2026 kommt die ersten zweieinhalb tausend Quadratgrade.
Und klein Irna 25 auch schon mal ein kleiner Ausschnitt oder?
Und davor kommt ein Jahr vor und das ist schon in einem guten Jahr von jetzt
an wahrscheinlich Januar Februar 25 kommt unser Quality Data Release.
Das sind nur 50 Quadratgrad.
Ich sag nur in sehr sehr großen Anführungszeichen.
Da kommen schon mal Bilder über 50 Quadratgrad.
So, muss noch genau ausgestaltet werden, was da exakt drin ist,
welche Daten und in welcher Form.
Aber das ist so viel Fläche, wie Hubble angeguckt hat.
Ja, nicht ganz in der Tiefe, nicht ganz in der Auflösung, wir haben eine halb
so gute Auflösung wie Hubble, nicht. So, Hubble ist ein Faktor 2 besser.
Aber das ist eine unglaubliche Fläche, da steckt so viel drin.
So viele hunderttausend oder Millionen von Galaxien, Sternen und sonst was.
Da können Leute wirklich ihre Instrumente dran schärfen für was immer an Datenanalysen,
die sie machen wollen später.
Da werden auch größere Mengen an Artikeln schon, Fachartikeln schon zu erscheinen.
Und ein Jahr später kommen dann zweieinhalbtausend Quadratgraben.
Das ist einfach eine Größenordnung, die man bisher von bodengebundenen Sachen
kennt, aber nicht mit der Qualität oder der, und Qualität meine ich wirklich
mit der Auflösung und der Tiefe und der Wellenlänge, wie wir sie bisher gehabt haben.
Und das wird sehr interessant. So und zwei Jahre später kommt glaube ich dann
siebeneinhalbtausend Quadratgrad und dann am Ende fünfzehntausend Quadratgrad.
Und die gehen relativ bald an die Welt und das wird dann einfach für alles mögliche
nutzbar sein, was Kosmologie und Nicht-Kosmologie ist. Ich suche eine Galaxie am Himmel irgendwo.
Ich gehe ins Archiv und habe ein Bild davon. In einer hohen Auflösung.
Nur um nochmal ein Gefühl dafür zu bekommen, wie anders die Daten jetzt sind.
Also würde man jetzt mal wirklich einen Ausschnitt nehmen, den Hubble beobachtet
hat und dann exakt denselben Bildausschnitt, was weiß ich, irgend so ein Deep
Field zum Beispiel. Also Hubble Deep Field fällt wahrscheinlich sowieso dabei raus.
Inwiefern haben die Daten, die jetzt von Euclid kommen und die Daten von Hubble,
also wie verhalten die sich zueinander? Wenn du sagst Hubble hat die höhere
Auflösung, was hat dann Euclid oder hat Euclid nur mehr?
Euclid hat, Euclid hat, also wenn ich eine einzelne Galaxie angucke,
dann können wir natürlich nicht gegen Hubble oder JWST gegen anstinken.
So wir haben eine Hälfte der Auflösung, was aber für,
die meisten Galaxien im Universum durchaus Daten liefert.
Hälfte von Hubble ist immer noch doppelt oder dreimal so gut wie vom Boden.
Das heißt, es ist alles besser als das, was man vom Boden bekommt.
Im Infraroten ist die Auflösung nicht ganz so gut, weil wir gröber gucken und
weniger Pixel haben und wegen der Wellenlängen abhängigen Auflösungsgenauigkeit.
Der Vergleich wäre aber auch hier wieder Boden. So und es gibt ein Tumors,
das ist ein Survey, der über den größten Teil des Himmels geht,
der ist sieben Magnituden heller,
guckt der Sachen an, wenn da, wo dort keine Objekte mehr sichtbar ist,
da fangen wir überhaupt erst an, Objekte zu sehen, weil alles,
was heller ist, da saturieren wir und da sind wir dann halt in der Auflösung,
in der räumlichen Auflösung sind wir um Faktor 5 oder sowas immer noch,
also 5 besser als vom Boden.
Hubble wird bei einzelnen Galaxien immer besser sein, aber wir können halt Dinge,
wofür Hubble mehrere Wochen braucht, um sie häppchenweise abzuhaken und zu beobachten,
das können wir dann in einem Schuss machen.
Wir kommen dann auf Sachen, wo wir auch wahrscheinlich schwache Objekte sehen,
die halt nicht ganz so schwach sind, aber wir kommen auf 24.
Magnitude, das ist relativ schwach, auch schon was, was Hubble-Daten angeht.
Und dann machen wir noch so sogenannte Deep Fields, wo wir 40 mal hingehen oder
50 mal hingehen im Laufe der Zeit und wo wir dann nochmal zwei Magnituden tiefer kommen.
Da sind wir bei 26. Magnitude und wenn man mit Magnituden umgeht,
das ist schon ziemlich flach und das sind dann halt 50 Quadratgrad,
so viel wie Hubble insgesamt jemals angeschaut hat, aber tief.
Das heißt, der große Vorteil von Euclid ist vor allem die große Abdeckung, kann man sagen.
Große Abdeckung, die ansonsten nur von der Erde möglich wäre mit Weltraumqualität an Auflösung.
Mit Weltraumqualität. Und Wellenlänge.
Und es ist halt wirklich diese Kombination. Dinge, die man entweder vom Weltraum
nicht in endlicher Zeit schaffen könnte, mit vorhandenen Teleskopen,
oder die man vom Boden aus nie in der räumlichen Auflösung oder ganz,
ganz schwierig in der Wellenlänge schaffen würde. Und das ist die Kombination.
Und dafür ist es einfach eine relativ simple Sache. Man guckt sechs Jahre,
sehr gezielt, mit einem sehr simplen Teleskop und bekommt diese Daten.
Und viele, viele hundert KollegInnen, mich eingeschlossen, freuen sich darüber,
aber die Sachen für alle anderen Sachen, alle anderen Wissenschaftsdinge brauchen zu können.
Und dann am Ende ist vielleicht noch Treibstoff über und dann am Ende haben
wir wahrscheinlich Lücken irgendwo in der Beobachtungszeit, wo wir nicht unseren
Kosmologie-Survey machen müssen.
Und dann werden vielleicht andere Vorschläge kommen, was man in der Zeit noch
machen kann. Vielleicht steckt irgendjemand vor, wir gucken dann doch die Milchstraße
an. So. Und da wird ganz spannend in, ich glaube, in drei bis vier Wochen demnächst kommt...
Von der ESA so ein erstes Schmankerl raus, es wird einen ersten Satz von ein
paar Early Release Observations geben,
Pretty Pictures, schöne Objekte am Himmel,
irgendwas mit Galaxien, die dann in die Öffentlichkeit gehen und im Januar sollen
dann irgendwie auch die Pixel Daten folgen und das wird,
ich hab ein, zwei solcher Sachen schon gesehen jetzt intern und das ist einfach
atemberaubend schön, da freu ich mich selber drauf. Ich bin gespannt.
Ja, es gibt ja so eine Krise gerade der Kosmologie, sagt man.
Manche Leute sagen das, ja.
Manche Leute sagen das, also es gibt sozusagen eine unklare Datenlage über wie
alt ist denn jetzt unser Universum wirklich und es hängt ja viel mit diesen
Beobachtungen zusammen, mit irgendwie Ausdehnung und wie ist es denn nun wirklich.
Alter gar nicht so, Alter, Alter, ja, bisschen auch Alter, ja.
Im Prinzip wir vergleichen, wenn Leute vergleichen Sachen, die,
die bei, sind wir wieder bei Plank, 379.000 Jahre nach Beginn des Universums
nach dem Urknall waren und Sachen, die später jetzt passieren.
Und da ist es auch egal, ob man 10 Milliarden Jahre zurückguckt oder 12 oder
jetzt, da unterscheiden sich die Hubble-Konstante ein bisschen und paar andere,
paar andere Parameter auch.
Ja, ob es eine Krise ist, wird gern geschrieben. Eigentlich ist es keine Krise,
sondern es ist eine Sache, aus der man was lernen kann.
Es ist nicht klar, ob das irgendwie bedeutet, dass wir deutlich andere Kosmologie nutzen müssen.
Euclid wird ganz viele kosmologische Parameter unabhängig nochmal bestimmen
für diesen späten Teil, also nicht den Plank-Teil, sondern den späten Teil.
Und das wird ganz interessant, und ich meine da geht ja auch hin.
Ist die dunkle Energie eine Konstante? Ist es eine kosmologische Konstante?
Ist es etwas, was sich im Laufe der Zeit verändert hat?
Und natürlich wenn sich die Beschleunigung verändert, dann wird sich auch die
Ausdehnungsgeschwindigkeit verändern und so, also dementsprechend.
Also meine Frage ist ja, wird Euclid etwas dazu beitragen diese Krise zu entschärfen?
Ich glaube wir werden einfach Daten, also ich glaube es ist ziemlich klar,
dass die frühen und späten Hubble konstanten Messungen in sich jeweils korrekt
sind und dass wir es hier nicht mit Datenproblemen zu tun haben.
Sondern dass das wohl wirklich so ist, dass diese Unterschiede wirklich so sind.
Ob das eventuell durch irgendwelche Kalibrationen früh und spät entschärfbar ist, ist unklar.
Wenn es aber etwas beizutragen gibt, versuche ich mal dialektisch daran zu gehen,
wenn es etwas beizutragen gibt aus dem Bereich, wir müssen besser verstehen,
was eigentlich die Massen- und Ausdehnungs- und Druckkomponenten im Universum sind,
Dann wird Euclid einfach den Datenhintergrund dazu liefern können,
der halt ganz anders ist, als nochmal genauer hinzugucken, wie denn das mit
den Super-Norway dort und dort ist und nochmal die Unsicherheiten,
diesen Datenpunkten für die Hubble-Konstante zu reduzieren.
Wir werden die Hubble-Konstante unabhängig bestimmen, aber wir werden halt auch
was viel tiefergehendes sagen über die Struktur des Universums und die Geschichte.
Und ich glaube, das wird auch auf diese Kosmologie, vermeintliche Kosmologie-Krise Einflüsse haben.
Krisenbewältigung durch Raumfahrt. Super. Knut,
vielen, vielen Dank für die Ausführungen zu diesem doch sehr weitreichenden,
dieser weitreichenden Mission und dem weitreichenden Projekt hier,
dem Universum wieder mal auf die Schliche zu kommen.
Das hält ja noch eine ganze Menge Mysterien bereit, aber man muss halt mal genauer hinschauen.
Man muss genauer hinschauen, wir tun's und wir sind jetzt alle sehr sehr froh,
dass es so wirkt, als ob wir wirklich in wenigen Wochen die ersten und wenn wir die ersten haben,
die zweiten und dritten und vierten Datenpunkte am Himmel sehen können und dann
geht es wirklich mit zehn Quadratgrad am Himmel pro Tag voran und es wird eine
Datenflut auf uns und auf die Welt einstürzen.
Die dann auch wieder interessante Herausforderungen bedeuten wird,
aber in einer sehr positiven Art.
Sehr schön. Gut. Vielen Dank für die Ausführungen. Gerne.
Ja und vielen Dank fürs zuhören. Das war's heute von Raumzeit,
auch endlich wieder Raumfahrt und damit geht's dann auch bald wieder weiter.
Ja und bis dahin sag ich vielen Dank fürs dabei sein und wir hören uns bald
wieder. Tschüss und bis bald.